İyi akşamlar arkadaşlar. 26 Şubat 2025 çarşamba günü saat 19.30 66. ders günümüz sondan bir önceki dersimiz.
Evet bu hafta pazartesi ve çarşamba günü demiştik ama çarşamba ve cuma günü olacak.
Daha sonradan Telegram grubunda bildirmiştim. Çarşamba günü zaten dersimiz vardı ama bir de cuma günü dersimiz olacak.
Evet o zaman kaldığımız yere bir geri dönelim hızlı bir şekilde değerli arkadaşlar.
Şimdi halen concurrency kütüphanesini öğrenmeye devam ediyoruz.
Ama belirli bir süreye sığdırmak çok zor. Gördüğünüz gibi çok fazla eleman var.
Yani belirli bir detay seviyesinde gidiyoruz ama çok sayıda öğe var ve her yeni C++ standartıyla daha da zenginleşiyor concurrency ilişkin kütüphane öğeleri ve bilin öğeleri.
Arkadaşlar şimdi şöyle bir hatırlayalım.
Burada hayati derecede önemli olan çok sık kullanılan araçlardan biri StudFuture sınıfıydı.
Tabi aslında StudFuture sınıfı tek başına kullanılmıyor değil mi?
Bir hatırlıktım StudFuture sınıfı türünden bir nesnenin GetFuture fonksiyonunu çağırarak Future nesnesini elde ediyorduk örneğin.
Aslında Future senkron ya da asenkron çalıştırılacak bir Colabal'ın arkadaşlar iletmek istediği değeri ya da Exception'ı ileten bir ne diyelim sınıf.
Aslında bir kereye mahsus kullanılacak bir iletişim kanalı var, bir Shared State var.
Promise nesnesi hatırlayın o Shared State'i değiştiriyor ve Future nesnesi de o Shared State'e erişerek bizim çalışan kodun sonucunda iletilmek istenen değeri ya da Exception'ı almamızı sağlıyor sınıfın interfezindeki fonksiyonları görmüştük.
Ama neden şimdi bunu hatırlatıyorum?
Arkadaşlar StudFuture nesnesi kullanmanın ya da oluşturmanın aslında birden fazla yolu var.
Yollardan biri ki bunu çok fazla kod örneğiyle gösterdik.
StudFuture nesnesini doğrudan biz Promise nesnesini kendimiz oluşturarak Promise nesnesinin GetFuture fonksiyonunu çağırarak elde ediyorduk.
Yani o iletişim kanalını fiilen biz Promise ve Future nesnelerini tanımlayarak oluşturabiliriz.
Buna yönelik çok sayıda örnek verdik.
Ama bir de hatırlayalım en son konu başlığımızda Async fonksiyonu vardı.
Async fonksiyonu yine Synchron ya da Asynchron, Asynchron ise arka planda bir thread oluşturarak bir Callable'ı çalıştırıyordu.
Fakat geri dönüş değerini Callable'ın bize yine bir Future nesnesi döndürerek veriyordu.
Her zaman Future nesnesinin Get fonksiyonu, Future nesnesini ne yolla elde etmiş olursak olalım Future sınıfının Get fonksiyonunu çağırdığımızda Get fonksiyonu bize bu değeri veriyordu.
Yani Future nesnesi kullanmanın ikinci yolu Async fonksiyonuna çağır yapmak.
Arkadaşlar üçüncü yolu ise Packaged Task isimli bir sınıfı kullanmak.
Ki bugün ilk konumuz bu Packaged Task sınıfı olacak.
Packaged Task sınıfını göreceğiz.
Yalnız şunu söyleyelim bakın.
Async arka planda bir thread oluşturuyor değil mi?
Senkron değil de asenkron çalıştıracaksa.
Thread'i de biz A arkadaşlar kendimiz oluşturabiliriz.
Stood thread türünden nesneyi oluşturarak ya da sarmalayıcı Stood C thread sınıfı türünden bir nesneye bir Callable vererek.
İki arkadaşlar Async fonksiyonunu çağırabiliriz.
Async fonksiyonu bizim için thread'i oluşturur.
Üç henüz görmedik ama inşallah onu da oraya kadar yetişemeyiz.
Bir dersimiz kaldı ama ilave ders koymayı düşünüyorum.
En azından canlı olmasa da videoları.
bizim henüz görmediğimiz C++17 standartıyla dile eklenen paralel algoritmalarımız var.
Yani STL algoritmalarından hepsini olmasa da bence büyük bir çoğunluğunu rahatlıkla diyebilirim.
Özellikle C++20'den sonra paralel olarak çalıştırma imkanımız var.
Yani biz thread'e hiç doğrudan kendimiz bulaşmıyoruz.
Bu çağırdığımız STL algoritmasının birinci parametresine algoritmanın asenkron çalıştırılmasını talep etmeye yönelik bir argüman geçiyoruz.
Böylece arka planında o paralel olarak çalıştırılması demek arkadaşlar birden fazla muhtemelen thread kullanılması demek.
Fakat future'da thread'i biz yine kendimiz oluşturuyoruz değil mi?
Yani biz bir promise nesnesini oluşturmakla bir thread'i oluşturmuş olmuyoruz.
Biz bir promise nesnesini oluşturarak aslında ne yapıyoruz arkadaşlar?
Onu bir thread'e argüman olarak gönderiyoruz.
Şimdi bunları bir özetledik.
Peki gelelim Packaged Ask sınıfına.
Arkadaşlar ama ismi aslında ne olduğunu büyük ölçüde belli ediyor.
Packaged hatta şöyle yazalım.
Burada belki ben telaffuz ederken artist olduğu anlaşılmayabilir.
Packaged Ask.
Şimdi Ask görev demek.
Arkadaşlar Packaged da herhalde açıklamaya gerek yok.
paketlenmiş demek.
Yani paketlenmiş görev.
Burada amaç bir kolubılı bir sınıf nesnesiyle o kolubılın ihtiyaç duyduğu arkadaşlar,
o kolubılı bir sarmalayıcı sınıf nesnesiyle sarmalamak.
Fakat bu kolubılı senkron ya da asenkron daha sonra çalıştırmak ve burada arkadaşlar Packaged Task'in fonksiyon çağrı operatör fonksiyonunu çağırdığımızda aslında arkadaşlar oradan bir ne alacağız?
Yine future nesnesiyle future nesnesi alacağız.
Yani daha doğrusu şöyle söyleyelim.
Get future fonksiyonunu çağırarak future nesnesi alacağız.
Ama future'ın get fonksiyonunu çağırarak tıpkı asinkte olduğu gibi future'ın get fonksiyonunu çağırarak da
efendim Packaged Task'in çalıştıracağı task'in burada bir kolubıl ilettiği değeri ya da exception'ı elde edeceğiz.
Yani buradaki çalışma mantığı şöyle.
Bir Packaged Task sınıfı türünden bir nesne oluşturulur.
Packaged Task'in kendisi de bir arkadaşlar generic sınıf.
Bu sınıf nesnesine bir task atanır ama bakın task atanır demekle o task çağrılır anlamında değil.
Sadece assign edilir.
Bunu constructor yoluyla yapabiliriz ya da daha sonra taşıma semantiğinden faydalanabiliriz.
Sonra bu Packaged Task nesnesini senkron olarak kullanabiliriz.
Yani aynı thread'te fonksiyon çağrı operatör fonksiyonunu çağırırız.
Ya da buraya dikkat.
Packaged Task sınıf nesnesinin kendisi de kolubul olduğuna göre.
Çünkü bir fonksiyon çağrı operatör fonksiyonuna sahip bir function object.
Bir factor class.
O zaman onu da ben bir thread'e taşıyabilirim.
Ve o thread benim iş yükü olarak, word load olarak benim Packaged Task'imin sarmaladığı kolubulu çağırabilir.
Yani burada kritik nokta aslında task nesnesini önceden oluşturup,
belki bazı verileri elde ettiğimiz noktada oluşturup,
ama task'in yürütülmesini ya da aynı thread'te ya da farklı thread'te yürütülmesinin çalıştırılmasını
daha sonra gerçekleştirebiliriz.
Bu da ciddi bize olanaklar sağlıyor.
Ama burada tekrar söyleyelim arkadaşlar.
Nasıl promise'in get future fonksiyonu varsa,
burada da bizim Packaged Task'imizin get future fonksiyonu var.
Yani biz aslında bu Packaged Desk'in sarmaladığı kolubulun çağrılması durumunda hazırladığı değeri
yine Packaged Desk'le ilişkilendirilmiş,
onun oluşturduğu shared state'e arkadaşlar erişim sağlayan future nesnesiyle kullanıyoruz.
Aleyhan Bozkır, Async'den daha mı yüksek seviyede bir araç?
Bence hayır.
Yani bu biraz da yoruma bağlı.
Çünkü bakın, Async'de hiçbir şekilde siz müdahale olmuyorsunuz.
Async'e argümanları gönderiyorsunuz ve Async'den doğrudan future nesnesini geri dönüş değeriyle alıyorsunuz.
Aşağı yukarı aynı seviyede diyebilirim.
Yani Async'le farkı, Async'in eğer asenkron çalıştırma argümanını geçersek,
bizim Async'i çağırır çağırmaz kolubulu çalıştırması.
Ama bunun Async'den farkı ne?
Biz Packaged Desk nesnesini oluşturuyoruz,
onun bir kolubulu sarmalamasını sağlıyoruz,
ama çağrılmasını daha sonra geciktirebiliyoruz.
Yani bunu aynı thread'te ya da başka bir thread'e ileterek çalıştırılmasını sağlayabiliyoruz.
Yani seviye olarak bence aynı seviyede kabul edilmeli.
Ama zaten kendi kararınızı şimdi görünce kendiniz vereceksiniz.
Arkadaşlar, başlık dosyası yine future.
Yani hem promise future sınıflarının başlık dosyası future,
hem de değerli arkadaşlar Async fonksiyonuna çağır yapmak için yine future header'ına ihtiyacımız var.
Yine package task için de arkadaşlar neye ihtiyacımız var?
Bizim future başlık dosyasına ihtiyacımız var.
Şimdi buraya dikkat, ben daha önceki derslerde fonksiyon türüyle,
function type ile function pointer type arasındaki farkı anlatmıştım.
Örneğin arkadaşlar, şöyle bir fonksiyon varsa demiştim,
ki bunu herkesin artık bildiğini biliyorum.
Bu fonksiyonun türünden bahsederken bu tür, bu şekilde gösterilen tür.
Hatırlıyorsunuz değil mi arkadaşlar?
Evet.
Ama bu fonksiyonun adresi olan türden bahsediyorsak o tür böyle bir tür.
Hatırlayınız, daha önce de karşımıza çıktı, konuşmuştuk.
Bu bazı arkadaşlar sınıfların, sınıf şablonların, yani jenerik sınıfların template parametresi bizden bir function type istiyor.
İşte bunlardan biri de stud package task.
Stud package task bir sınıf, tekrar tekrar söylüyorum, stud ama jenerik bir sınıf.
Yani bir sınıf şablonu, bakınız arkadaşlar, package task'in görüyorsunuz template parametresi bizden ne istiyor?
Aslında bir arkadaşlar callable type, bir function type istiyor.
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Yani örneğin, izleyin, yukarıdaki gibi bir fonksiyonu sarmalayacak package task sınıf nesnesini oluşturmak için şöyle yazmamız gerekiyor.
Şimdilik using directive'ini kullanıyorum.
Package task, arkadaşlar bakın bakın, int, int, virgül, int açılımı, specialization'ı.
Ve burada arkadaşlar bu artık nesnemizin türü.
İsim olarak genellikle task ismini kullanacağım.
Çünkü bu aynı zamanda programlamada task based programming denilen genel konunun da bir öğesi.
Ve default construct edebilirim ya da bir volu volu argüman olarak verebilirim.
İşte örneğin who.
Arkadaşlar şimdi soru.
Soru bir.
Dokuzuncu satırdaki kodun çalışmasıyla full fonksiyonunun kodu çalışmaya başlayacak mı?
Alian Bozkır, evet ya da hayır.
Az önce söyledim cevap, hayır.
Bravo.
Ne zaman arkadaşlar bu sarmalanan callable yani full çağrılacak?
Son derece basit.
Taskin, buraya dikkat.
Taskin.
Yani package task sınıf nesnemizin fonksiyon çağrı operatör fonksiyonunu çağırdığımızda aslında bu fonksiyon çağrılacak.
Ama işte fonksiyon çağrı operatör fonksiyonunu biz bulunduğu bu nesneyi oluşturan thread'te yani örneğin burada da çağırabiliriz.
Örneğin 3, 5 arkadaşlar.
Bunun arkadaşlar fonksiyon çağrı operatör fonksiyonunu nerede de çağırabiliriz?
Bu package task nesnesini bir başka thread'e taşıyarak bu thread'te de çalıştırabiliriz.
Yani nesneyi oluşturduğumuz noktayla fonksiyonu çağırdığımız nokta aynı thread'te farklı kaynak kod noktaları olabilir.
Mesela farklı fonksiyonlar olabilir.
Bir fonksiyon oluşturup bir fonksiyon da bu task'i çalıştırabilir.
Ya da bir thread'te oluşturulup başka bir thread'te de çağrılabilir.
Bir şey daha dikkatinizi çekmek istiyorum.
Alain Bozkır sitedden faydalanabiliyor muyuz?
Zaten bu soruyu sormaya bile gerek yok.
Alian zaten Alian da bu cevabı bildiği için soruyor.
Arkadaşlar bu zaten genel bir kural.
Constructor'dan çıkarım yapılabilecek her senaryoda sitatı kullanabilirsiniz.
Yani şöyle de yazabilirim değil mi?
Öyle de yazabilirim değil mi?
Kesinlikle.
Bu durumda değerli içi argüman olarak gönderilen callable'ın signature'ına imzasına bakarak template argümanının az önce gösterdiğim function type olduğunu anlayacak.
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Arkadaşlar bir şeye daha dikkatinizi çekmek istiyorum.
Bakınız task bu önemli.
Bir şey dikkatinizi çekiyor ama lütfen lütfen küçük pencere içine bakar mısınız?
Pencerte bakarız da ne görmemizi bekliyorsun?
Arkadaşlar işte bakın küçük pencere sizde görünüyor değil mi?
Bende gizli açılmıyor herhalde.
Küçük pencere içinde burada çağrılan package task sınıfının fonksiyon çağrı operatör fonksiyonunun parametrik yapısını görüyorsunuz.
Burada ilk dikkatinizi çeken nokta ne?
Deniz'e sorayım.
Deniz burada ilk dikkatinizi çeken nokta ne?
Evet ben olsam şunu söylerdim ama bir bekleyim.
Inline olması ama yok inline'ı kastetmedim.
Inline'ın hemen yanındakine bakın.
Arkadaşlar bu bir void fonksiyon.
Bravo.
Geri dönüş değeri yok.
Yani biz callable'ın geri dönüş değerini fonksiyon çağrı operatör fonksiyonunun geri dönüş değerinden almayacağız.
Git.
Öyle değil mi?
Nereden alacağız?
Oluşturduğumuz, elde ettiğimiz future nesnesinin get fonksiyonundan alacağız.
Yani bize geri dönüş değeriyle vermiyor.
Bize aslında arka planda yaratacağı shared state vasıtasıyla veriyor.
Onu görün.
Ama ikinci noktaya da dikkat çekerim.
Arkadaşlar bizim sarmalattığımız polibol'ın kaç tane parametresi varsa görüyorsunuz fonksiyon çağrı operatör fonksiyonunun da o kadar parametresi var.
Anlaşıldı mı?
Hadi gelin bir de neyi gösterelim.
Arkadaşlar bakın task nokta get future fonksiyonu tıpkı promise'te olduğu gibi.
Get future fonksiyonu da bize gördüğünüz gibi bir future nesnesi döndürüyor.
Şimdi soru artık yavaş yavaş araçları birbiriyle ilişkilendiriyorsunuz.
Soru auto ft eşittir task'in get future'ı dediğimde ft'nin türü ne olacak?
Tahmin etmeniz zor değil.
Promise ve future sınıflarını ince.
Bravo, bravo, bravo.
Arkadaşlar future'ın int açılımı.
Future'ın int açılımı.
Öyle değil mi?
Neden?
Çünkü colobal'ın geri dönüş değeri int olduğu için.
Colobal'ın geri dönüş değeri double olsaydı
task'in get future fonksiyonu da bize future'ın double açılımı türünden bir değer verecektir.
Kıpkı daha önce gördüğümüz gibi o zaman auto type deduction'dan faydalanmazsam
arkadaşlar burada ne diyebilirim?
future'ın future run int açılımı.
Arkadaşlar ft diyebilirim.
Evet task'in get future'ı.
future'ı takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Evet peki şimdi devam edelim.
Artık buraya dikkat.
artık bu fonksiyonun çağrıldığında biz neyi elde edeceğiz?
Arkadaşlar bu fonksiyonun geri dönüş değerini full'dan bahsediyorum.
future'ın get fonksiyonunu çağırarak elde edeceğiz.
Hadi gelin bir örnek yapalım.
En basit örneklerden başlayalım.
Arkadaşlar şimdi başlangıçta biraz
C++'ın birçok aracı birçok konusunda olduğu gibi
başlangıçta biraz zor geliyor ama sonra alışıyorsunuz.
Mesela bakın oluşabilecek, çağrılabilecek en basit fonksiyon olsun.
Mesela arkadaşlar sun square isimli bir fonksiyon olsun.
fonksiyonumuz iki tane parametre değişkenliğe sahip olsun.
Hatta bu any function anlamında ya
arka planda biz bunu task olarak yürüteceğiz ya
herhalde böyle bir toplama işlemi olmayacak tipik olarak
burada çalışan bir kod olacak.
Böyle durumlarda ne yapıyordum?
Böyle durumlarda sanki burada bir kod çalışıyormuş gibi
arkadaşlar bir gecikme sağlıyordum.
stut this thread'in sleeper fonksiyonu
buraya da ne diyelim stut krono milisekunds
pek sevmiyorum böyle yazmayı daha çok literal kullanıyorum
ama ya da milisekunds olmasın
peki milisekunds olsun
iki bin
iki bin ise zaten saniye yapardık
bari bin sekiz yüz yapalım değsin.
Ve return
A çarpı A
artı B çarpı B
evet
şimdi buraya kadar bir hata olmadığından emin olalım.
Arkadaşlar
evet A diyorum
demin A B ismini verecektim
ondan oldu.
X çarpı X
artı Y
çarpı Y
süper
hemen derleyelim
bir hata yok.
Şimdi bakın
önce basit bir çalıştırma
package task nesnesini oluşturuyorum.
stut package task
arkadaşlar
int
int int
ya da
az önce
Arihan Bey'in dediği gibi
neden de
faydalanabilirim
arkadaşlar
stuttan da faydalanabilirim
ama stutt
tabi hep tekrar ediyor
c++17
tesourist
task
ve
argument
olarak
konstruktora
fonksiyonun
arkadaşlar
adresini verdi.
Buraya kadar
tamam.
Ve yine
gösterelim ki
böyle yazmakla
örneğin
şöyle yazmak
arasında
bir fark yok.
İkincisi
sitattan
faydalanıyor.
Buraya kadar
tamam mı?
Tamam.
Arkadaşlar
hatta isterseniz
şöyle bir şey yapalım.
Bakınız
cout
sum
square
çağrıldı.
Önce
stream'i de dahil edelim.
sum
square
is
call
ya da
sadece
call
önce
şunu göstermek
istiyorum.
Bakın
package task
nesnesini
oluşturduk
arkadaşlar.
Programı
derleyip
çalıştırılırım.
Gördüğünüz gibi
çalışan
şu anda
herhangi bir
fonksiyon
yok.
Peki
soru
şimdi
buradan bir
future
olacağız değil mi?
Evet.
task'in
get
future
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
ve
geri dönüş
değerini
artık
future'ın
ya da
autopilot
deduction
future'ın
int
açılımı
türünden
bir
nesnede
saklıyorum.
evet
arkadaşlar
future
int
ne diyelim
f
eşittir.
tabii
stud
future
buraya kadar
her şey
yolunda
ama
tabii ki
future
nesnesini
aldık
izleyin
arkadaşlar
yine
fonksiyon
çağrılmadı.
şimdi
ben bu
fonksiyonu
doğrudan
burada
çağırabilirim.
İşte
senkron olur
o durumda.
Mesela
burada
bazı
kodlar var.
some
code
here
ve
çalıştıracağım
yerde
arkadaşlar
izleyin
çalıştıracağım
yerde
ben
burası olsun
kana kod
noktasında
ask
fonksiyonu
çağırıyorum.
İşte
on
ya da
dört
on üç
ve
f'in
get
noktasını
çağırıyorum.
Yine
aynı
daha önceden
olduğu gibi
ben
bir
exception'ı da
değeri de
almış
olabilirim.
Tıpkı
promise
future örneklerinde
olduğu gibi
hepsine
örnek vereceğiz.
Şimdilik ben
sadece
bunu
standart
altta
yazdırayım.
C
alt
value
is
f'in
geti.
Evet
görüyorsunuz
value
is
andırdın
et
f'in
Evet
Şuradaki
yazıyı da
düzeltelim.
Şimdi
bakın
burada önemli
birkaç nokta.
Arkadaşlar
şöyle yazsam
izleyin
auto
new
task
eşittir
bunu
sentaks
hatası
olmasıyla
neyi
göstermeye
çalışıyorum?
arkadaşlar
non
copy
able
peki
şimdi
bakın
copy
constructor
deleted
bravo
şimdi
bakın
stud
move
task
şimdi ise
bir sentaks
hatası
olmadı.
Buradan şunu
göstermeye
çalıştım.
Bizim
package
task
sınıf
nesnelerimiz
move
only
bir sınıf
olduğu için
kopyalamaya
karşı
kapatılmış
mesela
bakın
halen
senkron
çalıştıracağım
mesela
şöyle de
yapabilirim
izleyin
bir fonksiyon
var
arkadaşlar
bu fonksiyonun
parametresi
stud
package
task
üründen
stud
package
task
üründen
arkadaşlar
int
param
işte böyle
göstereyim
ve
ben
buradaki
full fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
elimde task var ya
full
şöyle yazsam
tabi yine
syntax
hatası
olacak
move
only type
olduğu için
ama
şöyle
yazabilirim
bakın
programın
akışı
buraya geldi
öyle değil mi
neyi
göstermek
için
kodu
yazıyorum
yani
aynı
thread içinde
bir başka
fonksiyonu da
olabilir
başka bir
fonksiyonu da
taşıyabilirsiniz
şimdi de
bakınız
full
ama
bunun içinde
ben
full
balımı
çalıştırıyorum
ama yine
bakın
full'yu çağırdıktan sonra
future'dan yine
alabileceğim
derliyorum
şüphesi önce
full çağırıldı
sonra
sum square
çağırıldı
ve gördüğünüz gibi
değeri aldım
şimdi size
çok güzel bir
soru soracağım
bakalım
soruya
güzel bir cevap
gelecek mi
birazdan
tabii ki
başka bir
threadle çalıştırma
örneği vereceğim
ama ondan önce
bir soru
sormak istiyorum
arkadaşlar
şimdi
burada bir şey
dikkatinizi
çekiyor mu
ben
volu balı
sarmalıyorum
ama
volu balın
ihtiyaç duyduğu
argümanları
sarmalamıyorum
alan
bozkır
burayı anladınız mı
dikkat ederseniz
örneklerin
hepsinde
argümanları
sağlayan
aslında
package test
nesnesinin
fonksiyon çağrı
operatör fonksiyonunu
çağıran
kod
alan
deniz
burası anlaşıldı mı
yiğit
evet
şimdi o zaman
soruya geçelim
peki
buraya dikkat
argümanları da
ben belirlemek
istesem
yani
argümanları da
package test
nesnesini
oluşturan
hod
ayarlamak
istese
ki bu çok
sık duyulan
bir ihtiyaç
onu nasıl yapacağım
hadi bakalım
akıl yürütme
yoluyla bir cevap
gelecek mi
soruyu anladınız mı
önce
evet
bakalım
arkadaşlarımızdan
kimler var
evet
Resul de
dersteymiş
Nazım Bey de
şöyle bir
yoklama alalım
Arut son derslerde
siz de soruyu
düşünün
Abdülkadir Akar
Alihan Bozkır
Deniz Akkuş
Mehmet Ali Ekeci
Nazım
Mamadli
Oğuzhan Esin
Resul
Mamedov
Samet Şengel
Belibayar
Yiğit İnce
o zaman
soruyu anladınız mı
en azından
buna bir evet
deyin
evet o zaman
soru anlaşıldı
perfect forwardingden
yararlanacağımız
bir mekanizma
olabilir mi
hayır
foo ya da
parametresiz
geçip
ekstra parametre
argümanı
almak nasıl olurdu
Deniz diyor ki
tekrar edebilir misin
soruyu
ben sorunun
anlaşılmadığını
düşünüyorum
o yüzden
tekrar edeyim
bakın
şimdi
bu örneklerde
son yazdığımız
2-3 örnekte
biz
package task
nesnesini
oluşturduk
böylece bir
kolabılı
örneğin bu örnekte
sum square
fonksiyonunu
sarmaladık
fakat
biz package task'in
fonksiyon çağrı
operatörünü
başka bir
threadle
ya da başka bir
kaynak kod
noktasında
çağırabiliriz
ama bu durumda
argümanları
işte bakın
bu örnekte
olduğu gibi
aslında
package task'in
fonksiyon çağrı
operatör fonksiyonunu
çağıran kod
sağlıyor
buraya kadar
tamam mı
Deniz
şimdi diyorum ki
hayır
bu argümanların
kendisini de
package task
sınıf nesnesi
adeta
sarmolasaydı
bunu nasıl
yapabilirdik
arkadaşlar
şimdi
izleyin
pointer kullanarak
değil
standart kütüphanenin
bir öğesi
vardı
hadi bakalım
hayır hayır
standart kütüphanenin
bir öğesi
vardı
functional
başlık dosyasında
uzun uzun
da konuştuk
functional
başlık dosyasında
bir
fonksiyon adaptörü
vardı
generalized
function
adaptör
hatırlayan var mı
bind
bravo
arkadaşlar
bind'ı
kullanabiliriz
bakın
bind
aslında
bir fonksiyonla
bu fonksiyona
gönderecek
argümanları
bağlamıyor mu
şimdi dikkat
o zaman
şöyle yapsak
bakınız
her şeyi siliyorum
functional
başlık dosyasını
bu
include ediyordur
bunlardan biri
ama ben yine
functional başlık dosyasını
include edeyim
arkadaşlar
önce
içten dışa
doğru yazalım
suit bind
bind'ın birinci parametresi
sarmalanacak
callable
arkadaşlar
yani
fool
öyle değil mi
evet
diğer parametreleri de
aslında bağlanacak
argümanlar
işte burada
underscore
bir
iki de
bind'ın
geri döndürdüğü
callable'ın
arkadaşlar
fonksiyon çağrı
operatör fonksiyonu
bizim fonksiyonumuzun
hangi parametresine
geçecek
onu
anlatıyordu
değil mi
ama ben şimdi
örneğin
10 ve 20
geçersem
söyleyin bakalım
burası çok önemli
bind'ın
geri dönüş
değeri olan
callable'ın
kaç tane
parametre
değişkeni var
soruyu tekrar
soruyorum
bind'ın geri dönüş
değeri olan
callable'ın
fonksiyon çağrı
operatörünün
kaç tane parametre
değişkeni var
bu durumda
iki cevabı
yanlış
üç cevabı da
arkadaşlar
hatırlayın
o konuyu unutmuşsunuz
argümanları
zaten
bağlıyor
hatırlayın
sıfır cevabı
doğru
zaten
argümanları
bağladım
zaten
bakın
iki tane
şöyle yazsaydım
hatırlıyor musunuz
bizim şu
placeholders
namespace'imizdeki
bu konu biraz
unutulmuş
çoktandır
arkadaşlar
yazmadığımız için
placeholders
namespace'inde
bulunan
argümanlar
vardı
değil mi
şöyle yazalım
placeholders
bu bir
namespace'ti
bu namespace'deki
argümanları
kullanıyorduk
böylece
mesela
burada
arkadaşlar
diyelim ki
underscore
biri
kullansam
bu ne
anlama geliyor
foo'nun
ikinci parametresine
şurada virgül olmadığı için
altını çiziyor
şöyle yazsaydım
hatırladınız
şimdi bind'in geri dönüşte
yeri olan
kollable'a
gönderdiğim
argüman
arkadaşlar
bir parametrelik
bir
kollable verecek
aslında foo'nun
ikinci parametresine
gönderilecek
dolayısıyla
eğer
soru böyle
olsaydı
şimdi bakın
herkesin hatırlamasını
sağlayacağım
soru böyle
olsaydı
bind'in geri
döndürdüğü
kollable'ın
fonksiyon çağrı
operatör fonksiyonunun
kaç tane
parametresi var
deseydim
Alian
şimdi de doğru cevap
verin
ne diyecektiniz
cevap bir
bravo
o zaman
tekrar söylüyorum
şimdi
Alian Bey'in
cevabının
neden doğru olduğunu
herkes anlıyor mu
şimdi
sıfır
süper
peki
o zaman
arkadaşlar
mesela bakın
isterseniz
deneyin
auto f eşittir
see out
f
arkadaşlar
iostream'e
dahil edeyim
fonksiyon
çağrı
operatör fonksiyonunu
böyle çağıracağım
değil mi
fu
özür dilerim
fu değilmiş
fonksiyon
arkadaşlar
tabi siz de haklısınız
ben fu
sum square
yazdığımı
zannediyorum
eğer o nedenle
şaşırdıysanız
haklısınız
tabi
ama zannediyorum
buraya sum square
yazdım
anlaşıldı
evet bakın
şimdi f'i
çağırıyorum
geri dönüş değeri
merak etmeyin
sorumuza geri döneceğiz
evet
sum square
called
gördüğünüz gibi
peki
o zaman
şimdi
artık
ilk
o zor sorumuzun
cevabını verelim
soru neydi
package test
nesnesini
oluşturan
callable ile
birlikte
callable'ın
fonksiyonuna
gönderilecek
argümanları
da sarmalamak
isterse
yanıt
bind'i
kullanacaksınız
kullanalım mı
bind'i
bind
fonksiyonumuzun
ismi
sum square
demin
yanlışlıkla
fu yazmıştım
fu'yi sevdim
şimdi
arkadaşlar
diyelim ki
hatta burada
değişkenlerimiz
olsun ki
runtime'da
çağrıldığı
belli olsun
yoksa
evet
bakın
sum square
x'in ve y'nin
değeri
şimdi dikkat
zaten bu ifade
bind'in geri
döndürdüğü
callable
öyle değil mi
package test
de
benden bir
callable
istemiyor mu
o zaman
stut
package test
efendim
pt
eşittir
ama tabi
burada
çıkarım
yapılamayacağı
için
arkadaşlar
ne yapacağım
template argümanını
yazacağım
nasıl
kritik yerlerden
biri de bu
hadi bakalım
bu durumda
package test
kin
açısal parantezi
içine
yani o template argümanını
yazdığım yere
ne yazmalıyım
arkadaşlar
söyleyin
cevap
hayır hayır
decletarptan
bahsetmiyorum
bravo
Mehmet Ali
ekici
artık
fonksiyonun
parametresi
yok ki
int
function
type
bu
gördünüz mü
bravo
Mehmet Ali
evet
çünkü parametresi
olmayan
geri dönüş
değeri olan
bir tür
şimdi artık
kolubulumuzun
türü
değişti
şimdi efendim
ben örneğin
yine
package
task
kin
get future
fonksiyonunu
çağırsam
get future
fonksiyonundan
aldığım
future
nesnesini
artık
arkadaşlar
bu fonksiyonun
çağırıldığı
buralarda
kodlar var
şimdilik hep
asenkron
değil
çalıştırdım
artık
burada
pt'nin
get fonksiyonunu
çağırabilirim
yani
şimdi
burada
yazacak
değer
34'ün
karesi
artı
13'ün
karesi
olan
arkadaşlar
bu bekleme
halen
devam ediyor
başka bir yerde
bir hata
yapmadıysak
evet
bind'in
sum square
pt'nin
çağırmamışız
fonksiyonu
evet
eskin ismi
neydi
pt
şimdi oldu
fonksiyonu
çağırmamış
evet
şunu da
kapatalım
süper
evet
bakın
şimdi
sum square
çağırıldı
ondan
arkadaşlar
her şey
yoluna oturdu
eğer
package
task'in
sarmaladığı
fonksiyonun
argümanlarını
package
task'in
fonksiyon
çağırı
operatör fonksiyonunu
çağıran
kod
verecekse
zaten
onu yapmanın
yolu
başta
konuştuğumuz gibi
ama
argümanların
birini ya da
birden
fazlasını
siz belirleyecekseniz
o zaman
stut
bind'ı
kullanıyorsunuz
peki
necok
şimdi
farklı
thread'de
çalıştırmayı
da
bir gösterilmesi
tabi tabi
aslında
orasını
siz de
tahmin ediyorsunuz
package task'i
oluşturduğum
yer
yine ben
using
direktifini
kullanayım
package task
arkadaşlar
task
yine aynı
isim olsun
sum
square
ama
auto
future
eşittir
task'in
get
future'ı
izleyin
void
who
evet
arkadaşlar
izleyin
ya da
doğrudan
şurada
thread'i oluşturalım
bakın
şimdi
thread'i oluşturuyorum
evet
buraya bir izleyin
thread
e
şimdi
kritik yer bence
burası
tb
thread
nesnesi
değil mi
evet
peki
thread'in
arkadaşlar
biz
parametresine
ne geçiyoruz
cevap
callable
geçiyoruz
peki
task'in kendisi de
bir callable
mı
cevap
evet
task'in kendisi de
bir callable
o zaman
task'i de geçebilirim
ama tek dikkat etmemiz
gereken şey
kopyalamaya karşı
kapalı olduğu için
sput
muğla
vereceğim
task'i
arkadaşlar
bir de
argümanları
vermem gerekiyor
değil mi
o zaman
argüman olarak da
diyelim ki
line tasarım
alamadığıma göre
10 ve
20'yi
vereyim
böylece bu thread
koşmaya başladı
bu thread
olabilirdi
peki thread olsun
thread'si
t
join
ve
netlikten sonra
da
mesela
see out
the result
is
ptr'nin
yeti
artık bunun
ana kısmı
anlaşıldı
bundan sonrası
bol bol
örnek yapmaya
girer
evet
bakınız
some square
called
the result
is
peki
şimdi
thread'i oluşturdum
peki
exception
true
ederse
hadi bakalım
buraya bu sefer
bir if
deyimi koyalım
arkadaşlar
if
x
eşit eşit
sıfır
ya da
y
eşit eşit
sıfır
o zaman
bu ne fonksiyonuysa
bu yanlışmış
true
std
except'i dahil ediyorum
except
true
suit
invalid
argument
evet
negatif
zero
argument
error
ama böyle bir durum
yoksa
kimse bana şunu
sormuyor
değil mi
necat
some square'de
x ya da
y sıfır
olursa
neden
exception
true
etsin ki
yani
tabi ki öyle
bu herhangi bir
fonksiyon ve
exception
true
göstermemiz
gereken o
yani ismiyle
uyuşmadığını
şu anda
biliyoruz
evet
ama
eğer sıfır
değilse
x kare
mesela buradan
sıfır elde edilmemesi
gerekiyormuş
çarpı
y kare
evet bakın
şuraya kadar
hiçbir fark yok
peki
nerede fark var
sadece şurada
eğer
bakın
exception
true etmişse
o exception'i
bu noktada
yakalamak
istiyorsanız
ne yapacaksınız
tabi ki
hatırlayın
try blow'unu
alacaksınız
arkadaşlar
exception
bot
yanlış yeri
ya alta yazmışım
zaten
evet
şunu
try blow'u
içine alıyorum
hapar
onu niye
try blow'u
içine alıyorum
saçmalık
geti çağırdığım
yer neresiydi
orası silinmiş
tamam
şurada geti
çağırmıştım
fp'nin
geti
siyahut
evet ama
exception
yakalanacak
işte böyle
argümanları değiştirelim
un ve sıfır olsun
şimdi
callable'dan gönderilen
exception
burada
yakalandı
yani
nasıl
biz
daha önce
async'de olduğu gibi
promise future'de olduğu gibi
promise'in
set value
fonksiyonuyla
değeri
set ediyorduk
set exception
fonksiyonuyla da
exception'ı
set ediyorduk
burada da
değişen herhangi bir şey
yok
arkadaşlar
buraya kadar
anlamadığımız bir şey var mı
evet
arkadaşlar
şimdi
senkron ya da
asenkron kullanılabilir
onu konuştuk
mesela
burada şöyle bir örnek
yazmışım
bu arada
github'da
concurrence kısmını
çok yakında
tamamlayacağım
bitmek üzere
sadece notlar kısmı
kaldı
mesela burada
o sefer
bir lambda function
arkadaşlar
constructor'a
argüman olarak
gönderildi
evet
bu da
a üzeri b
artı
b üzeri a'yı
döndürüyor
future destesini
aldım
ama daha sonra
fonksiyonu
burada çağırdım
evet
ama artık
bundan sonra
aynı
çok basit
kodları
tekrar etmeyelim
sadece karmaşık olan
örneklere bakalım
çünkü
bundan sonrası
yine
aynı değil mi
mesela
ben
future'ı
aldıktan sonra
burada
ayrı bir thread
oluşturabilirdim
thread
e
sub thread
burada
mc değişkenimin ismi
ptask
2.3
4.5
önce ayrı bir thread
çalıştırılmış
olacaktır
evet
buraya kadar
anlamadığımız
bir şey var mı
arkadaşlar
yine bir lambda
verebilirim
bind'ı
yani
bind'ın
döndürdüğü
kolu balı
verebilirim
herhangi bir kolu balı
doğrudan bir
function object
verebilirim
mesela bakın
daha yine
örneği beraber yazalım
bu sefer
future
başlık dosyasını
dahil ettim
ielstream'i
thread
başlık dosyasını
dahil ettim
şu klasik
fibonacci
fonksiyonuna
yazalım
yine
recursive
int
ne diyelim
n
yani n
burada fibonacci
serisinin
n'inci
derimi
anlamında
return
n
küçük
örneği
operatör
o zaman
aksi halde
pip
fibonacci
serisini
hatırlıyorsunuz
ya da biliyorsunuz
n-1
artı
pip
n-2
bu tür örneklerde
fibonacci
rekürsif
yapılmasının
nedeni
daha önceden
de hatırlayıp
çok zaman
alıyor
özellikle büyük
değerler için
rekürsif çağrının
maliyeti
son derece
yüksek
değil mi
evet
arkadaşlar
şimdi
olu olu olarak
doğrudan fibi
verebilir miyim
tabii ki
o zaman
package task
ne açılımı
aslında şöyle yazdığım
package task'in
int
açılımı
arkadaşlar
f task
fibonacci
task'ten
ve
pip
arkadaşlar
doğrudan
thread'i oluşturayım
thread
e
ya da
c thread'i
olabilirdi
stud move
f task
ama bir de
argüman lazım
mesela
bu thread
koçmaya
başladı
arkadaşlar
main track
burada
bekliyor
see out
waiting
for the task
to
finish
bekledi
ama
biz
future
nesnemizi
alacağız
onu almamışız
şurada alalım
auto
ne diyelim
fd
eşittir
f task'in
get future'ı
ve
get
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyoruz
join'den sonra da
önce de
çağırabilirsiniz
arkadaşlar
see out
value
is
hatta şöyle
diyelim
neydi bizim
yerimiz
zaten
değişken
değilmiş
dilim
pt'nin
tt
hatta buraya
şimdi yazdıralım
the task
is
completed
now
join
join edin
derleyelim
bakalım
isen
taks
hatası
var mı
evet
çalıştıralım
41'inci
değer
şuymuş
baya büyük bir sayı
milyon
580 bin
küsür
45'inciye
alalım
oldu ama
orada yine
yazıyor
arkadaşlar
şimdi bundan sonraki örneklerin
çoğunu
doğrudan
copy paste yapacağım
çünkü çok fazla
kod var
yani
genel olarak
göstermek istediğim
bundan sonra
package testine
neler yapabiliriz
bu sorunun
cevabı
farklı
kod örneklere
mesela birden fazla
task oluşturabilirim
bunları
bir vektörde
tutabilirim
vesaire
bunların
örnekleri
şimdi şu örneğe
bir bakalım
evet bakın
şimdi burada
ne yapıyorum
çok dikkatli izleyin
arkadaşlar
görüyorsunuz
fung fonksiyonunun
parametresi
package test
lvalue referans
burada fung önemli
fakat
ikinci parametresi
bir
pair vektörü
ama
pair'in de
int int açılımı
package task'in de
int
yani geri dönüş
değeri int
parametresi
int int olan
function type açılımı
burada
yine
siyah hat nesnesini
senkronize ediyorum
Mehmet abi
birazdan bakayım
sorunuza
evet ve
13. satırdaki
for döngüsünde
yine
ne deniyordu
buna
arkadaşlar
range base
for loop
ama
structure binding
kullanıyorum
böylece
vektörü dolaşıyorum
vektörden
ama vektörü
dolaşırken
önce
ptask'in
get future'ını
çağırıyorum
future'ı
aldım
vektördeki
pair'den
aldığım
elemanlarla
task'i
çalıştırdım
ve sonucunu
yazdım
burada
aslında göstermek
istediğim bir şey
de reset
fonksiyonu
arkadaşlar
future'ın
future'ın diyorum
package task'in
reset fonksiyonunu
çağırarak
aynı
task nesnesi
için
tekrar fonksiyon
çağrısı
yapabilirsiniz
temel olarak
async
task'ten
bir farkını
görmedim
bizim
kaçırdığımız
bir şey
olmalı
kaçırdığımız
şey şu
aslında
3-4
kere
vurguladık
async'i
siz çağırıyorsunuz
Mehmet Ali
çağırdığınız
noktada
thread çalışıyor
öyle değil mi
fakat burada
bir task'i
sarmalıyoruz
ve task'i
istediğimiz
bir yerde
çalıştırıyoruz
senkron ya da
asenkron
async ile
bunu yapamayız
şimdiye kadar
yazdığımız örnekleri
gösteririm
mesela
diyelim ki
ben task'i
oluşturdum
fakat
onu
çağıracağım
nokta
başka bir
thread
ama
belki başka
bir zaman
sadece
elimde
her an
çalıştırılabilir
bir task
var
o task'i
ne zaman
çalıştıracağım
tamamen
benim programımın
lojik yapısına
bağlı
burada
diğer arkadaşlarım
farkı anladı
değil mi
async'i böyle
çağırıyorum
async
diyelim ki
collable
argümanlar
async bana
doğrudan
neyi veriyor
arkadaşlar
future nesnesini
veriyor
ama async
burada thread'i
çalıştırıyor
öyle değil mi
ama şimdi burada
durum bambaşka
ben package test
nesnesini
oluşturarak
bir thread'i
çalıştırmıyorum
sadece
sarmalamayı
yapıyorum
ve böylece
onu
başka bir
kaynak kod
noktasında
bunların
hepsini
söyledim
senkron olarak
ya da
başka bir
thread'de
asenkron olarak
çalıştırabilirim
yani
keski oluşturan
kodla
keski
çalıştıran
kod
aynı
thread'de
olmak zorunda
değil
aynı
kaynak
kod noktasında
olmak zorunda
değil
Mehmet
abi
anladınız mı
evet
async daha çok
şöyle
async nasıl
async'i
çağırıyorum
diyorum ki
her şeyi sen
hallet
ben sana bir
collable
veriyorum
argümanları
da veriyorum
bunu
benim için
asenkron
çalıştır
bana da
bir future
ver
ben future'ın
get fonksiyonunu
çağırayım
evet
peki
şimdi az önceki
örneğe geri dönelim
burada
örneğin
vurguladığı
reset fonksiyonu
yani
arkadaşlar
package task'in
reset fonksiyonu
var
reset fonksiyonunu
çağırırsam
ondan
tekrar bir
future alıp
tekrar
task'i çalıştırıp
aynı
tabi argümanları
geçeceğim
yine ondan aldığım
future nesnesini
tekrar
ne yapabiliyorum
kullanabiliyorum
evet
şimdi bakın
mesela bu da
aslında Mehmet Ali Bey'in
sorusunun
bir yerde cevabı
arkadaşlar
bakın
burada
dataları oluşturdum
aslında
task'leri
bu
değer çiftleriyle
çağıracağım
ve package task'i de
oluşturdum
bakın
tam Mehmet Ali
sizin sorunun
sorununda
bir örneği
ama
bu noktada
herhangi bir şekilde
çalışan
bir fonksiyon
var mı
yok
ama şimdi bakın
burada
belki bu başka
bir fonksiyonda
olabilirdi
trade'i
burada çalıştırdım
arkadaşlar
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
evet
gördüğünüz gibi
trade'i
burada çalıştırdım
punk fonksiyonuna
arkadaşlar
package task'i
ve
efendim
vektörü
argüman olarak
verdim
ve
aslında
çağrılan
şu
tabi aşağıda
tekrar yazmışım
aslında
çağrılan
burada
fonksiyon
nerede
burada
ve
defalarca
bu vektördeki
bütün öğeler için
çağırıyorum
arkadaşlar
paralel çalıştırma
reset tam olarak
nasıl çalışıyor
normalde
siz
bir
promise nesnesinden
bir kez
future
olabilirsiniz
ama şimdi
ptask'in
reset fonksiyonunu
çağırdığınız zaman
tekrar artık
get future
ile yeni bir
future
olabiliyorsunuz
yani
sarmalanmış
test değişmiyor
sadece
sarmaladığı
kolu bulu
ikinci kez
çağırabiliyorsunuz
ve
ikinci kez
çağırdığınızda
bu sefer
ikinci bir future
nesnesine
ihtiyacınız var
evet
arkadaşlar
bakın şimdi
Mehmet Ali Bey
farkını anlamadım
dedi ya
bir başka örnek
bakın
bu örnek
aslında konuyu
çok güzel gösteriyor
olanaklardan
bir tanesi daha
biraz
örnek tabi
fazla bir
koda sahip
ama ana fikri
anlamanız önemli
şimdi yavaş yavaş
gidelim
ne yapıldığını
birlikte görelim
burada
summer
isimli bir
arkadaşlar
function object type var
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
aslında bunun
şöyle bir fonksiyonu var
fonksiyon çağırı
operatör fonksiyonu
ne yapıyor
arkadaşlar
bu değerden
bu değere kadar
olan sayıların
toplamını
alıyor
hesaplıyor
yani burası
işin hikaye kısmı
işte ben
summer'ın
fonksiyon çağırı
operatör fonksiyonunu
çağırdığımda
örneğin
5 ve 20
değerleriyle
çağırdığımda
5'ten 20'ye
kadar olan
sayıların
toplamını
bulacak
ama şimdi
bakın
4 tane
ayrı
summer nesnesi
oluşturdum
efendim
buradaki
fonksiyon
türünün
eş
ismini
oluşturdum
ftype
her defa
aslında şunu
tekrar etmemek
için
ve arkadaşlar
package test
ftype
tabi burada
ototip
şunu da yapamaz
mıydım
izleyin
bunu hiç
kullanmadan
sitattan
faydalanamaz
mıydım
cevap
faydalanabilirdim
fark farklı
araçları
göstermek için
tamam
bakın
şimdi
Mehmet Ali Bey
get future'ı
hepsi için
çağırdım
oysa
ortada
daha çağrılan
bir fonksiyon
yok
package test
leri
tutacak
bir
konteyner
oluşturdum
görüyorsunuz
burada
deck
konteynerını
kullandım
ama
deck'in
package test
int virgül
int açılımı
ve
test leri
bu konteynera
koydum
arkadaşlar
bakın
buraya kadar
daha çağırdığım
hiçbir fonksiyon
yok
ama ben
test leri
bir konteyner
da tuttum
şimdi
artık
bu
konteynerı
bir başka
trade'e de
gönderebilirim
bir başka
fonksiyona da
gönderebilirim
ama bu
konteynerı
dolaşıp
oradaki
package testteki
arkadaşlar
testlerin
fonksiyon
çağrı
operatörünü
çağırabilirim
yani bu
testleri
çalıştırabilirim
demek
arkadaşlar
bakın
şimdi
begin ve
increment
değişkenleri
1.2500
ant değişkeni
begin
artı
increment
takip edebiliyor
musunuz
evet
şimdi
ne yapıyor
konteyner
boş
olmadığı
sürece
arkadaşlar
konteynerın
front fonksiyonunu
çağırarak
hatırlayın
front fonksiyonu
konteynerdaki ilköğe
erişiyordu
onu
buradaki
değişkene
taşıdı
sonra
top from
fonksiyonunu
çağırarak
onu
konteynerdan
çıkarttı
bir
thread oluşturdu
bakın
thread'i burada
oluşturuyorum
arkadaşlar
thread'i
oluşturdu
döngünün
bir sonraki
durumda
efendim
değerler değişti
orası bizi
ilgilendirmiyor
ama
döngünün
her durumda
oluşturduğum
thread'i
deteç
ediyorum
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
ama arkadaşlar
sonuçta elimde
buradan alınmış
future nesneleri
var değil mi
ister
deteç
edeyim
ister
join
edeyim
ben
bu
future
nesnelerinin
get fonksiyonlarıyla
geri dönüş
değerlerini
alabilirim
işte
mesela
Mehmet Ali
bu örnekteki
işi
stud
async ile
yapma
imkanın
var mı
cevap
hayır
aldım
testleri
konteynere
koydum
efendim
daha sonra
thread'leri
oluşturdum
vesaire
evet
arkadaşlar
devam edelim
şimdi
bir iki örnek
daha yapalım
ondan sonra
konuyu
değiştirelim
exception ile
alınabileceğini
söyledik
yani
fonksiyon
çağır
operatör fonksiyonunu
çağırdığım zaman
exception
throw ederse
exception'i
yakalayabiliyorum
değil mi
evet
peki
burada şöyle bir problem var
izleyin
arkadaşlar
burada şöyle bir problem var
peki
package test nesnesi
bir
kolabılı
sarmalamış
olma
durumunda mı
her zaman
böyle olmak zorunda mı
cevap
hayır
Alihan diyor ki
async deferred ile
sonra çağırabiliriz
ama
thread oluşturulmaz
değil mi
evet
arkadaşlar
async'de onu görmüştük
şimdi bakın
package test boş da olabilir
package test'in boş olup olmadığını
yine package test'in
valid fonksiyonuyla
sınayabiliyorsunuz
bir örnek
arkadaşlar
arkadaşlar bakın
şimdi
test 1
yavaş yavaş
gelelim
şurada
evet
bakınız
burada
bizim
kolabalımızın
geri dönüş değeri
ve parametresi
olmadığı için
package test'in
void
parametresiz
function type
açılımı
test 1
default
construct edildi
şu anda
buna bir
test
asign edilmiş
hiç değil
ama test 2'ye
test verildiği için
onun geçerli bir test'i var
yavaş yavaş
gidiyorum
bakın
şimdi
valid fonksiyonunu
çağırdığımda
test 1
valid fonksiyonu
test 1 için
çağrılan
false döndürecek
arkadaşlar
böylece
false döndürdüğü için
ben
empty olduğunu
anlayacağım
eğer
true döndürürse
o zaman
empty olmadığını
anlayacağım
derleyip
çalıştırıyorum
test 1 boş
test 2
dolu
yani
valid durumda
şimdi
taşıma semantinden
faydalanıyorum
test 2'yi
test 3'e
taşıdım
oysa
test 2
validti
şimdi
test 2
invalid hale
gelecek
yani boş
olacak
test 3 ise
dolu hale
gelecek
buradan
şunu anlıyoruz
package task'in
çağıracağı
bir fonksiyon
var mı
sorusunun
cevabını
aslında
sınıfın
bull döndüren
valid
fonksiyonuna
çağrı yaparak
elde ediyoruz
evet
peki devam
peki
boşken
fonksiyon
çağırsam ne olur
mesela
şöyle bir senaryo
olsun
arkadaşlar
bunu
neyle
karıştırmayalım
future'in
get'inin
exception'ı
kabul etmesi
yani
promise nesnesiyle
set exception
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorduk
hani future'ın
get'ini çağırdığımız zaman
aynı exception
throw ediyordu
onunla karıştırmayalım
ama burada da bir
exception
throw edecek
ama buradaki
exception'ın
nedeni farklı
buradaki exception'ın
nedeni
şimdi yazacağım
kodda
aslında
valid olmayan
bir package
task var
fakat
fonksiyon çağrı
operatör fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorsunuz
yani şöyle bir durum
bakınız
şunu da silelim
package task'in
efendim
int
int açılımı
ptask
autoft
eşitleri
ptask'in
get future'ı
ve
tiktar
key task
fonksiyonu çağırıyorum
orası çağırılacak bir
task vermedik ona
işte bu durumda
future error
throw edecek
runtime'a bakın
evet
arkadaşlar
bir dakika
ptask
on
dedik
argüman gönderdik
evet
const
exception
evet
normalde
exception
göndermesi lazım
ama
durun bakalım
try
ptask
eksek bir şeyim var
diye bakıyorum
intent
future'ı
ha future'ı
almadan
tamam
şimdi anlaşıldı
arkadaşlar
future'ı
almışım
o yüzden
evet bakın
exception
code
must
burada
future
error
sınıfı
türünden
bir
exception
gönderdi
evet
arkadaşlar
şüphesiz
burada
eski
ne de
yapabiliriz
bir
thread'de
çalıştırıp
o thread'ı
detach
edebiliriz
ama biz onu
detach etmiş
olsak bile
get fonksiyonunu
çağırdığımızda
yine
future'da
gördüğümüz gibi
bloke
olacak
şu örneğe
bakın
artık birkaç
tane daha örnek
yapalım
atomik
konusuna
geçeceğiz
evet
şimdi
burada
ptx
ve pty
pty
dolu
ptx
boş
yine
kopyalamanın
syntax hatası
olduğunu
çünkü
move only type
olduğunu
gösterdik
pt
underscore
x
package
task
değişkenine
taşıdık
onun
future'ını
aldık
farklı bir
thread'de
çalıştırdık
arkadaşlar
bakın
şurada
idiomatik
bir yapı
yani
biz normalde
şöyle yapıyoruz ya
bu idiomatik
yapıyı da gösterelim
normalde şöyle
yapıyoruz
değil mi
stot
thread
px
diyelim ki
arkadaşlar
px
detach
yani
amaç
buysa
nesneyi
isimlendirmeye
de gerek yok
stot
thread türünden
geçi bir nesne
oluşturun
geçi nesnenin
doğrudan
detach
fonksiyonunu
çalıştırın
böylece o
geri planda
arkadaşlar
çalışmaya
devam edecek
ama
ne zaman ki
biz future'ın
get fonksiyonunu
çağıracağız
o zaman
get fonksiyonunu
çağırın
thread
eğer iş
bitmemişse
bloke
olacak
ama tabi
detach
çağırırken
çok dikkatli
olmak gerekiyor
daha önce
konuşmuştuk
arkadaşlar
şimdi
bir de şunu
gösterelim
async'de biz
bir algoritmanın
paralel çalıştırmasına
örnek vermiştik
hatırlıyor musunuz
async'i
dört kere
accumulate
fonksiyonunun
paralel
çalıştırılması
accumulate
değildi
başka bir şeydi
belki de
accumulate
paralel çalıştırmasına
bir örnek verdik
dört tane
ayrı thread
yarattık
yani async fonksiyonla
farklı argümanlarla
dört tane
farklı
arkadaşlar
çağır yaptık
yani dört
thread'de
çalıştırmıştık
bakın aynısını
şimdi
izleyin
kodun tamamının
üstünden
geçmeyeceğim
arkadaşlar
şimdi
bu
accumulate
s
fonksiyonu
aslında örnek
birebir aynı
daha önce
yazdığımız örnekten
ama orada
async'i
kullanmıştık
burada
package
test'i
kullanıyoruz
şimdi
on altıncı
satırda
tanımı
başlayan
accumulate
parallel
fonksiyonunun
parametresi
uint
türünden
elemanlar
tutan
bir vektör
const
referans
aslında
daha önce de
olduğu gibi
arkadaşlar
paralel
çalıştıracağım
ama bakın
bakın şimdi
ne yapıyorum
önce test'leri
oluşturuyorum
test'lerin
hepsine
arkadaşlar
şu
accumulate
underscore
s'i
bağladım
yani
böylece
dört tane
package test
nesnem var
burada
tabi
uzun uzun
şu
fonksiyon
türünü
yazmamak için
türeş
ismi
kullandım
ama tabi
belki de
bu örneği
hazırladığım
zaman
bu
C++17'den
önce
olmalı
çünkü
C++17 ile
zaten burada
ne yapılıyor
sitatla
template
argümanlarının
çıkarımı
yapılıyor
bakın
test'i
oluşturdum
dört tane
future
nesnesi
aldım
ama
thread'leri
burada
oluşturdum
yani
aslında
thread'ler
c-thread
nesneleri
burada
thread'leri
çalıştırdı
tabi
geçerken
yine
test'ki
sağ tarafta
değeri yapmak için
stud
move
fonksiyonunu
argüman olarak
gönderdim
ama burada
elde ettiğim
future nesnelerinin
get fonksiyonlarını
çağırarak
aslında
işte bu
orayı anlatmaya
gerek yok
her bir
thread
vektörün
bir bölü
dörtlük
kısmının
kümülatif
toplamını
hesaplıyor
ama bunlar
paralel koştuğu
için
biz
dört ayrı
thread
eğer sequential
olsaydı
hepsini
bekleyecektik
ama şimdi
dört ayrı
thread bu işi
yaptı
tabi thread
oluşturma
maliyeti de
var
onu her zaman
söylüyoruz
muhtemelen
daha kısa
sürede
ne olacak
tamamlanacak
arkadaşlar
peki
tak iç
test ile
ilgili
aslında
çok da
bunun dışında
konuşacak
fazla bir şey
yok
şimdi asıl
zor konumuz
başlıyor
arkadaşlar
yani
bence
maalesef
concurrency'nin
en zor
kısmı
atomik işlemler
arkadaşlar
programlama
dillerinin
çoğu
atomik işlemlere
izin veriyor
ama
atomik işlem ne
demek
önce onu
biraz konuşmamız
gerekiyor
sonra
c++'ın
standart
kötü bahanesi
atomik işlemler
için hangi destek
ya da destekleri
veriyor
bunları konuşacağız
arkadaşlar
burada aslında
kullanılması gereken
terim
atomik operation
yani
atomik değişken
programlama dilinden
bağımsız
söylüyorum
atomik değişken
öyle bir değişken ki
o değişkenle
ilgili yaptığımız
bazı işlemler
yani
İngilizcesi
operation'lar
atomik bazda
yapılıyor
yani
bu garantiyi
veriyor
ama şimdi
işlemin
atomik olması
ne demek
arkadaşlar
işlemin atomik
olması
işlemin
kesintiye
uğramadığı
anlamına geliyor
yani
kesintiye
uğramaz
burada İngilizce'de
kullanılan terim
uninterruptible
yani
işlem
tamamlanmadan
başka bir
threat
oraya müdahale
edemez
yani
kritik bölge
oluşturmasanız
bir kilit
sistemi
kullanmasanız
dahi
atomik işlem
yapılırken
bir atomik
değişken
üstünde
arkadaşlar
başka bir
threat
ya o
işlem yapılmadan
önceki
state'ini
görecek
ya da
o işlem
yapıldıktan
sonraki
state'ini
görecek
bu da şu
demek
atomik
değişkenler
üstünde
yapılan
atomik
işlemler
söz konusu
olduğu zaman
sizin
bir
mutex
kullanmanız
gerekmiyor
atomik
değişkenler
ne
garantisini
veriyor
işlem
kesintiye
uğramayacak
arkadaşlar
bakın
işlemin
kesintiye
uğraması
ne demek
burası
çok önemli
aslında
en temel
noktalar
siz şimdi
diyelim ki
en basit işlem
artı artı
x işlemini
yapıyorsunuz
biz
programlama
dilinin
sentaksıyla
böyle bir
ifade eden
deyim
yapıyoruz
ama
bu tür
işlemler
yani
örneğin
bir nesnenin
değerini
değiştiren
işlemler
aslında
genel olarak
şöyle söyleniyor
read
modify
write
işlemleri
yani
önce x'in
değerini
elde ediyoruz
sonra o değeri
bir toplanıyor
bunlar ayrı
makine işlemleri
makine
instructionları
olduğunu düşünün
sonra tekrar
o bellek alanına
yazılıyor
bu da ne demek
bu read
modify
write
arasına
başka bir
thread geldiğinde
bunu
ilk değeriyle
ya da
o arkadaşlar
değişmiş değeriyle
görmek zorunda
değil
bir date
arayısı
oluşuyor
o da
tanımsız
davranış
eğer
işte siz
atomik değişkenlerin
verdiği bu
garantiyi
atomik değişken
kullanmadan
eğer
elde etmek
isteseniz
o zaman
kritik bölge
yapacaksınız
orada bir
mütex
kullanacaksınız
oysa
atomik değişkenler
diyor ki
benim üstümde
yapılan işlemlerde
araya
kimse
giremez
o işlem
yapılana kadar
o atomik değişkeni
bir başka
thread
kullanamaz
şimdi
alan diyor ki
bunu nasıl
sağlıyor
bunu da
işte
ilerledikçe
göreceğiz
bunu sağlama
ya özel
makine komutları
instructionlar
kullanılıyor
ya da
o C++'ın
standart
tüphanesine
geldiğimizde
göreceğiz
kendisi
arka planda
bir kilit
sistemi
kullanıyor
şey
bu
bir
atomik tür
haricindeki
bütün
atomik türler
için
arkadaşlar
C++
standartı
implementasyona
yani derleyiciye
kilitle
ya da kilit olmadan
bu
atomistiyi
sağlama
hakkı
vermiş
bir tane tür
var ki
orada kilit
olmamak
zorunda
yani
doğrudan
makinenin
kendi
instruction'ı
olmak zorunda
o zaman
şimdi
atomik işlemlerin
diyoruz
özellikleri
neler
bir
uninterruptible
arkadaşlar
iki
kesinlik
yani kesinlik
derken
kastetilen şu
atomik işlem
ya tamamen
gerçekleşecek
ya hiç
gerçekleşmeyecek
yani
herhangi bir
şekilde
daha önce
şu terimleri
kullanmıştım
sanırım
torn read
ya da
torn write
olmayacak
mesela yarısı
değişmiş
halde
başka bir
thread'in
onu görme
şansı
yok
arkadaşlar
evet
şimdi burada
atomik operasyonların
önemli bir özelliği
daha var
şimdi asıl kritik yer
burası
arkadaşlar
atomik operasyonlar
sadece
işte bu
kesintiye
uğramama
özelliğine
sahip
değil
atomik operasyonların
sağladığı
başka bir
avantaj
işte bugün
bütün bunları
yavaş yavaş
görmeye
başlayacağız
thread'lerin
senkronizasyonunu
sağlamak
yani örneğin
bir thread
atomik bir
değişkene
set ettiğinde
başka bir
thread
onun
set edilmiş
olması
state'i
ne
gözleyebilir mi
cevap
evet
bu şekilde
bir
senkronizasyon
sağlanabilir mi
cevap
evet
zaten şimdi bakın
multi thread
programlamada
birkaç tane
problem var
o problemlere
yönelik de
araçlar var
problemlerden biri
biliyoruz
data race
yani
multi thread
programların
çok büyük
çoğunluğunda
aslında biz
paylaşılmış
paylaşımlı
değişkenleri
ya da
kaynakları
kullanıyoruz
burada
data race
olmaması
gerekiyor
onu konuştuk
ama
ikinci
önemli
nokta
senkronizasyon
sağlamak
burada
senkronizasyon
derken
kastedilen
şu
örneğin
bir thread
bir işlemi
yapacak
o işlem
yapıldıktan
sonra başka
bir thread
çalışacak
yani
sırf bu amaç
bir senkronizasyon
konusu
olabilir
ya da
daha da
önemlisi
bir thread
çalıştığı zaman
o threadin
oluşturduğu
sonuçlar
çalışan
başka bir
thread
tarafından
görülmüş
olma
garantisine
sahip
olacak
böylece
örneğin
iki tane
thread
önce biri
derken
bunlar eş
zamanlı
çalışıyor
ama
belirli bir
noktaya
geldiğinde
diğeri
onun
bir şekilde
işlemlerini
yapmasını
bekliyor
ve
nasıl bir
garanti
elde ediliyor
senkronizasyonda
tamam işte
ben bu
noktaya
geldiğimde
artık
benim
falanca
değişkenlere
ulaştığım
durumda
o değişkenler
başka bir
thread
tarafından
set edilmiş
durumda
bu garantiyi
elde ediyorsunuz
evet
işte bu
atomik operasyonların
sağladığı
önemli garantilerden
biri
İngilizce
ordering
deniyor
yani
bir işlemin
diğer işlemden
önce yapılması
değil sadece
ve sonra
örneğin başka
bir thread de
onun
sonuçlarının
gözlenebilir
durumda
olması
arkadaşlar
şimdi
C++'ın
standardı
burada
aslında
çok önemli
tanımlar
yapıyor
bence
atomik operasyonlara
geri döneceğim
ama bence
ilk olarak
programcının
neyi bilmesinde
fayda var
bu terimler
ne anlama geliyor
çünkü her şeyin
başı
bu terimler
ben şöyle bir not
aldım sizin için
biraz bekleteceğim
arkadaşlar
bu terimleri
şimdi aynı zamanda
açıklarken
şöyle tanımları
benim oluşturduğum
tanımları da bir
göstermek istiyorum
evet
şimdi bakın
sadece
tanımlar kısmına
bakın
arkadaşlar
birinci tanım
sequence before
şimdi
C'de kullanılan
terminolojiyle
C++'da kullanılan
terminoloji
birbirinden
farklı
sequence before'a
ben Türkçe bir karşılık
uydurmak istediğimde
şu karşılığı verdim
sıralı öncelik
garantisi
sequence before
ne demek
bir kere
sequence before
aynı
thread içindeki
işlemlerin
sırasını
tanımlıyor
yani
eğer
sequence before
terimi
kullanılıyorsa
bir kere
tanım gereği
biz tek bir
thread'den
bahsediyoruz
mesela
şimdiye kadar
concurrency konusuna
gelmeden önce
yazdığımız
C++
kodları
işte
mesela bu
kaynak dosyada
main fonksiyonu
çalışacak
ana thread
başka bir thread
de olmayacak
ve burada
sequence before
dediğimiz
bir ilişki var
sequence before
ilişkisi
şu demek
arkadaşlar
bir işlem
diğer işlemin
sonuçlarının
görünmesinden
sonra yapılıyor
yani örneğin
A ve B
iki tane
operasyonsa
izleyin
eğer
A
sequence before
B ilişkisi
varsa
bu şu demek
B işlemi
yapılırken
A işleminin
ürettiği
sonuçlar
B'de
görülüyor
olmak
zorunda
mesela
sequence before
oluşturan
en temel nokta
B'yim sonları
değil mi
mesela bakın
burada şöyle bir kod olsa
X eşittir
diyelim ki
A
Y eşittir
X artı 5
sadece
sorumu anlamaya
çalışın
arkadaşlar
böyle bir kod
yazarken
hiç biz şöyle bir
risk düşündük mü
ya derleyici
optimizasyon
yaparsa
ya
Y eşittir
X artı 5
X'e
A'nın değeri
atanmadan önce
yürütülürse
biz belki böyle
formal bir terim
kullanmadık
ama hep şu
garantiye göre
yazdık
değil mi
hiç kimse
şundan
şüphelendi mi
ya
Y
yedinci satırdaki
kod çalışırken
X'in değeri
henüz değişmemiş
olabilir
işte
hatırlayın
C'de
ben C kursunda
üstüne çok duruyordum
C'de
sequence point
diyorduk ya
şimdi C++'da
kullanılan terim
arkadaşlar
sequence before
bu ne demek
bir işlem
yapıldığında
eğer A ve B
arasında
sequence before
ilişkisi varsa
B
A'dan sonra
yapılacak
A'nın
sonuçları
B'de
görülür olacak
işte bakın
az önce verdiğim
tanımda
bu A olsun
arkadaşlar
bu B olsun
çok dikkatli
izleyelim
biz şundan
eminiz
değil mi
arkadaşlar
B'ye
yürütüldüğü zaman
artık
X'in değeri
değişmiş
olmak zorunda
işte bunun
formal tanımı
sequence before
ama sequence before
sadece
nerede yok
uzun uzun
girmek istemiyorum
sadece
deyim sonlarında
yok ki
mesela
izleyin
expression
virgül
bu virgül
operatörü
virgül
operatörü de
bir sequence
before
oluşturuyor mu
işte bakın
kesinlikle
tek tek
saymayacağım
bu A
arkadaşlar
bu B
A
sequence
before
B
A
sequence
before
B
yani
A
B'den
önce
yapılma
sıralı
öncelik
garantisi
taşıyor
hangi
operatörlerde
bu garanti
var
logic
veya
operatöründe
logic
veya
operatöründe
virgül
arkadaşlar
ve
turner
operatörde
C'de
böyle
fakat
C++'da
artık
C++
standardıyla
birlikte
atama
operatöründe
de bu
garanti
var
ama
şimdi
konumuz o
değil
oraya
girersek
çıkamayız
mesela
C'de
Alihan
X eşittir
X artı
artı
tanımsız
davranış
değil mi
cevap
evet
ama
bakın
mesela
C++'da
artık bu
tanımsız
davranış
değil
C++'da
burada da
sequence
before
ilişkisi
var
o zaman
şöyle
devam
edelim
sequence
before
dediğimiz
zaman
anlaşılması
gereken
ne
ortada
tek bir
thread
var
tek bir
thread
içindeki
operasyonlar
arasındaki
bir ilişki
biri A
biri B
diyelim
eğer A
sequence
before
B ise
A
B'den
önce
yürütülecek
ve
B yürütülürken
artık A'nın
oluşturduğu
sonuçlar
B'nin
yürütülmesi
sırasında
görülür
olacak
visible
tekrar
buraya
geri
dönüyoruz
arkadaşlar
bakın
tek thread
bağlamında
tek
threadli
programlarda
food'un
yazıldığı
sıraya
göre
işlemler
sequence
before
ilişkisine
sahiptir
ama
sadece
bu
değil
değil mi
çünkü
sequence
before
garantisi
veren
başka
yerler de
var
ama
dedik ki
o bizim
konumuz
değil
arkadaşlar
sequence
before
thread
için
geçerli
fakat
threadler
arasındaki
ilişkiyi
tanımlamıyor
yani
bu ne
demek
mesela
şöyle
olsaydı
arkadaşlar
efendim
burada
bir işlem
var
bir thread
de yapılıyor
başka bir
thread
de başka
bir işlem
var
bunların
arasında
sequence
before
ilişkisi
var
diyemeyiz
yani
eğer biz
ilave bir
mekanizma
kullanmazsak
bir thread
de yapılan
işlem
başka bir
thread
de
o işlemin
sonuçlarının
görülüyor
olma
garantisi
yok
işte
burada
ikinci
tanım
devreye
giriyor
ikinci
tanım
İngilizce'de
happens
before
deniyor
bu
C++'da
çok sık
kullanılan bir
terim
happens
before
bir kere
happens
before
dendiği
zaman
bir kere
arkadaşlar
işin içinde
bir
thread
söz konusu
threadler arası
bir
ilişki
arkadaşlar
happens
before
ilişkisi
aslında
şunu
söylüyor
bir işlemin
sonucu
başka bir
işlem yapılırken
görülür
olmak zorunda
Necati demir
sequence
before
için bunu
söyledi
zaten
sequence
before
aynı zamanda
happens
before
ilişkisi
sağlıyor
ama
happens
before
sequence
olmak
zorunda
değil
çünkü
happens
before
farklı
threadler
arasında
da
olabilir
arkadaşlar
mesela
bir
threadde
yapılan
işlemin
sonucu
garantili
olarak
başka bir
threadde
görülüyorsa
böyle bir
garanti
varsa
işte
biri
bir
threaddeki
ona
A diyelim
diğer
threaddekine
B diyelim
A ve B
arasında
bir
happens
before
ilişkisi
var
arkadaşlar
sadece
söylediğim yere
bakın
bir de
standartın
kullandığı
üçüncü
terim
inter
thread
happens
before
yani
bu arada
asıl
standart
iki tane
terim
kullanıyor
inter
arkadaşlar
kendi içinde
demek
ama
inter
birden fazla
arasında
demek
işte
inter
thread
happens
before
dediği
zaman
yine
happens
before
ilişkisi
ama özellikle
vurgulanan
ne
bir tane
bir operasyon
bir threadde
diğer operasyon
başka bir
threadde
ama
yine
dil
ne garanti
veriyor
ya da
standart
ne garanti
veriyor
bir threadde
yapılan
işlemlerin
sonucu
diğer
threadde
artık
görülür
olmak
zorunda
işte
bakın
eğer
inter
threads
happens
before
varsa
yani
bir
threaddeki
işlemin
başka bir
threadde
görülüyor
olma
garantisi
varsa
buna da
İngilizce'de
synchronized
with
ilişkisi
deniyor
daha doğrusu
ilişkisi
değil de
senkronize
olmuştuk
diyelim
Türkçeyde
arkadaşlar
bakın
şimdi
nerelerde
senkronizasyon
var
bu
çok çok
önemli
bir soru
mesela
ben şöyle
bir soru
sorsaydım
şuraya
yazayım
burada bir
thread
oluşturuyorum
i
thread
arkadaşlar
bakın
burada
some
code
here
izleyin
ve burada
thread'i
çalıştırdım
thread
px
u
arkadaşlar
ve argümanları
verdim
şimdi
soru
burası
çok önemli
aslında
bizim
ilk
gördüğümüz
happens
before
ilişkisi
burada
ama siz
bunun
belki
farkında
değildiniz
ya da
böyle
düşünmedik
ama
şimdi
aslında
biz bu
garantiye
sahibiz
değil mi
onu
hissettik
mesela
buradaki
kod
buraya çok
dikkat
buradaki
kod
bir
sonuç
oluşturuyorsa
bu
çalışan
thread'de
o sonucun
görülür
olma garantisi
var mı
a var
b yok
yani
samkodir
yazdığım
yerde
bir
sonuç
oluşuyorsa
tx
thread'i
koşarken
bu
sonucu
kullanma
garantisi
var mı
mesela
necattin
ne demek
istiyorsun
ya son derece
basit
mesela
x eşittir
ya da
orada
global bir
değişken
olsun
ne olduğu
önemli değil
x eşittir
bu thread
koştuğunda
x'i
5 değeriyle
bulma
garantisi
var mı
Alihan
cevap
var
işte
işte bu
aslında
bir
senkronizasyon
biz farkında
olmasak da
burada bir
senkronizasyon
var
yani
arkadaşlar
burası
buna
a diyelim
thread
çalışan thread'e
b diyelim
a ile b
arasında
bir
had not
before
ilişkisi
var
peki
devam edelim
bu thread
arkadaşlar
watch
to
izleyin
ve
bu sefer
burada
bazı
kodlar
var
some
code
here
ve
burada da
thread'i
join
ettim
px
join
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
peki
soru
join
fonksiyonu
çağrıldıktan
sonra
bu
kod
noktasında
yani
ünlemleri
koyduğum
kod
noktasında
arkadaşlar
ünlemleri
koyduğum
kod
noktasında
bu
çalışması
bitmiş
thread'in
oluşturduğu
sonuçlardan
sonuçların
görülür
olma
garantisi
var mı
cevap
evet
işte
burada da
bir
senkronizasyon
noktası
var
biz fark
etmesek
de
biz aslında
hep buna
güvenerek
kod
yazdık
değil mi
mesela global
değişkeni
bu thread
değiştirdi
arttırdı
biz burada
global
değişkeni
kullandığımızda
onun artık
o işlemlerin
sonucunun
görülmüş
olma garantisinden
hep
faydalandık
ama formal
olarak bakarsak
standart
bütün bu
durumları
ne olarak
alıyor
happens
before
ilişkisi
olarak
alıyor
başka
nerede
happens
before
ilişkisi
var
daha birçok
yerde
bakın
şimdi ne
dedik
thread
başlangıçlarında
join
ettikten
sonra
ondan
mutexlerle
yapılan
kilit
işlemlerinde
şimdi de
şunu
düşünelim
bakın
yine
happens
before
ilişkisi
olduğunu göreceksiniz
izleyin
burada
siz bir mutex'i
kilitliyorsunuz
mtx
lock
burası
sizin
kritik bölgeniz
mtx
unlock
burada tahmin
edebiliyor musunuz
iki tane
happens
before
ilişkisi
var
nedir
biri
arkadaşlar
izleyin
bu
kilidi
aldıktan
sonra
kilidi
aldıktan
sonra
aslında
bundan
önce yapılmış
işlemlerin
burada yine
gerçekleşme
garantisi
var
kilidi
kritik bölge
içinde yapılan
kodların
çalışmasından
sonra da
yani
unlock
fonksiyonunun
çağrılmasından
sonra da
kritik bölgede
yapılan
değişikliklerin
yine başka bir
thread de
arkadaşlar
görülür
olma garantisi
var
şimdi bakın
burada iki tane
yapması
before var
bir
başka bir
thread
bu
ben kilidi
edinmeden
önce
bir
sonuç
oluştursa
ben kilidi
edindikten sonra
o sonucun
oluşma garantisinden
faydalanabiliyorum
değil mi
aynı şekilde
unlock
için de böyle
bir garanti
var
yani ben
kilidi
unlock
ettiğimde
müodex'e
unlock
ettiğimde
artık
burada
yani o
kilitliyken
oluşturulmuş
değişikliklerin
görülür
olma garantisi
var
başka bir
thread de
olsa da
işte bakın
nasıl
yine
condition
variable
kullanımında
var
onu şimdi
örnek olarak
vermiş ama
biliyorsunuz
aslında
weight
fonksiyonu
örneğin
o da
bir ne
oluşturuyor
senkronize
sağlanma
ilişkisi
oluşturuyor
ya da bir
senkronizasyon
oluşturuyor
aslında
senkronizasyon
derken
kastetilen de
bu
biz şimdiye
kadar hep böyle
bir değişkeni
korumak
anlamında
kullandık
ama
senkronizasyon
aslında ne
bir takım
işlemler
yapıldı
bitti
ondan sonra
bir takım
işlemler
farklı
threadlerde
olsa da
yapılıyor
nasıl bu
saydığım
noktalarda
arkadaşlar
happens
before
ilişkisi
varsa
üstelik
inter
thread
happens
before
ilişkisi
varsa
bu
inter
thread
happens
before
ilişkisini
sağlamanın
önemli bir
aracı da
ne
atomik
değişkenler
yani biz
ilk önce
başlangıçta
şöyle
dedik
atomik
operasyonlar
bölünemez
yani
bir işlem
ya yapılacak
ya
bitecek
yapılmasıyla
yapılırken
bitene kadar
başka hiçbir
kodun ona
müdahale etme
şansı
yok
dolayısıyla
örneğin
x
az önce
söylediğim
gibi
bir
atomik
değişken
olsa
artı
da
atomik
bir
işlem
olsa
çünkü
atomik
değişkenliği
yapılan
bütün
işlemler
atomik
olacak
anlamında
değil
bu ne
demek
buraya
100 tane
thread de
girse
arkadaşlar
buraya
dikkat
x'i
ya artmış
değeriyle
bulacaklar
ya artmamış
değeriyle
tanımsız
davranış da
olmayacak
bu arada bir yanlış
anlama olmasın
artmış değeriyle
bulmasıyla
artmamış değeriyle
bulması
deterministik
değil
ama sonuçta
arkadaşlar
ya artmış
değeriyle
ya da artmamış
değerle
bulacak
evet
Mehmet Ali
hocam
bunu hangi
granularitede
yapıyor
diyelim iki
thread var
ve ikinci
thread de
sadece
ikinci global
variable'a
erişiyor
ikinci
thread için
sadece bu
iki değişken
için
garanti ediliyor
aslında
anlamak
istediğim
internal
olarak
tüm
cache mi
invalidate
ediliyor
sadece
kullanılan
değişkenlerin
bulunduğu
cache
arkadaşlar
şimdi yine
burada
şöyle bir
düşünce
hatası
var
daha doğrusu
düşünce
hatası
demeyelim de
modelleme
hatası
var
şimdi
belki
başka ortamlarda
böyle düşünmeye
alışmış
olabilirsiniz
arkadaşlar
c++
standardı
hiçbir zaman
bu terimleri
kullanmıyor
yani
o cache mi
var bu cache mi
var
o beni hiç
ilgilendirmiyor
yani bir cache
sistemi de
olmak zorunda
değil
beni ilgilendiren
şu
dilin verdiği
garantiler
neler
onlar da
daha önce de
konuşmuştuk
c++
abstract
machine
denilen bir
tanım var
o tanım
üstünden
yapılıyor
yani
standarda
bakarsanız
bütün
bu
sizin
sorduğunuz
soruların
cevabını
işte
formal olarak
bu
sequence
before
happens
inter
threat
happens
before
bu terimlerle
anlatıyor
dolayısıyla
size
ilgilendiren
bir işlemin
sonucunun
diyelim ki
başka bir
threadte
görülür
olma garantisi
var mı
yok mu
önemli olan
onu anlamanız
yani arka
planda bunun
nasıl yapıldığının
bizimle
doğrudan
bir ilgisi
yok
yani bu
atomik bir
değişkenle
yapılabilir
condition
variable
yapılabilir
bir kilit
sistemiyle
yapılabilir
işte zaten
benim amacımda
bunları göstermek
mesela
atomik değişkenlerin
avantajı ne
dezavantajı ne
kullanma temaları ne
bunları göstermek
ama
korkarım biraz
uzattık
saat
21.15
arkadaşlar
21.35
de devam edeceğiz
arkadaşlar
şimdi
az önce söylediğim
garantilerin
olduğu yerleri
biraz hızlı
yazdım ama
burada
tek tek
bir
göstermek
istedim
bakın
bu noktalarda
senkronizasyon
garantisi var
ama
burayı iyi
anlamak
gerekiyor
az önce
aslında
Mehmet Ali Bey'in
sorduğu sorunun
cevabı da
burada
şimdi şurayı
yeni göreceğiz
ama ben yine de
okuyayım
yazdığımı
atomik bir
değişken üzerinde
yapılan
stor işlemi
arkadaşlar
stor ona
değer yüklemek
anlamında
yani set
atomik bir
değişken üzerinde
yapılan
stor işlemi
yapıldığında
iki kere
olmuş
aynı
atomik
değişken üzerinde
load işlemi
yapıldığında
yapan
thread
stor işlemi
yapılmadan
önceki
bellek
işlemlerini
görür
bu ne demek
bunu ilerleyen
dakikalarda
göreceğiz
yani
benim bir
atomik değişkenim
var
bir threadte
önce
bellekte
bazı
değişiklikler
yapıyorum
yani
nesnelerin
değerlerini
değiştiriyorum
sonra
atomik
değişkenin
stor fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
yani ona bir
değer
yüklüyorum
başka bir
threadte
aynı
atomik değişkende
load işlemi
yaptığı zaman
buraya dikkat
diğer
threadte
stor işleminden
önceki
bellek işlemlerinin
sonucu
load'dan sonra
görülür
olmak zorunda
yani oradaki
storla load
arasında
bir
senkronizasyon
ilişkisi var
condition variable
bunu zaten
aslında formal olarak
söylemedik ama
hissettik
bir thread
condition variable
notify one
ya da
notify all
çağrısı
yaptığında
yani
condition variable
notify one
ya da
notify all
fonksiyonlarından
birini
çağırdığında
diğer
threadte de
aynı
condition variable
tabii ki
aynı condition
variable
olması gerekiyor
bunların
hepsinde
bir
aynılık
var
yani
atomik değişken
aynı olacak
condition variable
mutex
aynı olacak
belki demin
onu söylemedim
arkadaşlar
diğer threadte
aynı
condition variable
da
wait çağrısı
yaptığında
yani
condition variable
wait fonksiyonunu
çağırdığında
bu ne demek
işte
notify ile
wait arasında
bir
senkronizasyon
ilişkisi var
bu ne demek
arkadaşlar
notify
çağrısından
önce
yapılan
bellek işlemleri
wait çağrısından
sonra
görülür
olmak
zorunda
kilit
mutex
arkadaşlar
bir mutex
siz kilitlediniz
ve sonra
bir takım işlemler
yapıp
kilidi açtınız
kilidi açtığınız zaman
yani
unlock
ettiğiniz zaman
o kilidi
başka bir
thread
ama aynı
mutex
den bahsediyoruz
o kilidi
başka bir
mutex
o kilidi
o mutex
başka bir
thread
kilitlediği anda
işte oradaki
unlockla
lock arasında
bir senkronizasyon
ilişkisi var
yani bu ne demek
kilit
bendeyken
değişkenlerin
değerini değiştirdim
paylaşımlı
değişkenlerin
sonra kilidi
açtım
yani unlock
ettim
ama başka bir
thread kilidi
elde etti
benim yaptığım
işlemlerin
bellek işlemleri
diğer
thread'te
yani
mutex'i
kilitleyen
thread'te
yine görülür
olmak zorunda
thread başlangıçları
bunu söylemiştim
bir thread
başlatıldığı zaman
yani siz
stut thread
nesnesini
oluşturdunuz
ona bir
iş yükü
verdiniz
onu
başlatan
threadle
arkadaşlar
başlatılan
thread arasında
bir
senkronizasyon
ilişkisi var
yani
başlatılan
thread
başlatan
thread'in
bellek işlemlerini
görür
yani bu ne demek
arkadaşlar
şimdi
ben
thread'lerden
birindeyim
thread'i yarattım
thread tx
arkadaşlar
evet
fakat
bu
thread'i
başlatmadan
önce
burada
bellek işlemi
yaptım
bellek işlemleri
yani değişkenlerin
değerini değiştirin
örneğin
peki
bu thread
koşmaya
başladığında
bu bellek işlemlerin
sonucunu
görmek zorunda
mı
arkadaşlar
cevap
evet
işte
thread başlangıcı
senkronizasyon
sahalar derken
kast edilen
bu
thread sonlanması
yine bir thread
sonlandırıldığı
zaman
yani
join çağrıldığı
zaman
sonlandıran
thread
sonlandırılan
thread'in
bellek işlemlerini
görür
bu ne demek
ona da bir örnek
verelim
bu sefer
burada
join'i
çağırıyoruz
arkadaşlar
join'i çağıran
thread
join edilmiş
thread'in
oluşturduğu
bellek işlemlerinin
sonucunu
görme
garantisine
sahip
ondan sonra
bir de
demin belki
söylerken
bu eksik kaldı
future promise
arkadaşlar
future'da promise
bir kanal
oluşturuyordu ya
diyelim ki
bir thread
ki bunu zaten
fiilen yaşadık
bir thread
gitti
set value
fonksiyonunu
çağırdı
promise nesnes
üstünde
o promise'ten
elde edilen
future'ında
başka bir threadle
get fonksiyonu
çağırıldı
işte buradaki
setle get
yine senkronize
yani
set value'yu
çağırmadan önce
arkadaşlar
yapılan işlemler
set value'dan sonra
getten sonra
görülür olmak zorunda
burada işte
bütün senkronizasyon
noktalarını
söyledik
arkadaşlar
bunun dışında
bir garanti yok
şimdi burada
en büyük yanılgı
ne biliyor musunuz
mülakatlarda da
bunu sorma
ihtimalleri yüksek
size şöyle bir
soru sorsalar
bir thread'de
yapılan
işlemin
zamansal olarak
diğer thread'de
yapılan
işlemden
önce olduğu
biliniyor
bakın bak
soru çok önemli
önce olduğu
biliniyor
burayı tekrar okuyalım
bir thread'de yapılan
işlemin
zamansal olarak
diğer thread'de yapılan
işlemden
önce olduğu
biliniyor
yani bakın
bir A thread'i var
A thread'inde
yapılan
işlem
gerçekten
zamansal olarak
ölçtüğümüzde
diyelim ki
diğer thread'de
yapılan
işlemden
uyduruyorum
10 mikrosaniye
20 mikrosaniye
20 milisaniye
daha önce
bu garanti veriliyor
peki böyle bir
garantinin
olması
yani işlemin
zamansal olarak
daha önce
yapılması
diğer thread'in
o işlemin
sonucunu
görme garantisini
içeriyor mu
yani size böyle
bir şey
söyleseler
bu thread'deki
bu işlem
diğer thread'deki
işlemden
20 milisaniye
daha önce
yapıldı
o zaman
20 milisaniye
sonra yapılan
diğer thread'deki
işlemde
artık o
20 milisaniye
önce yapılan
işlemin
örneğin
bir değişkenin
değerini
değiştirmişse
sonucunu
görmek
zorunda mı
hayır
işte bakın
bir şey
zamansal olarak
önce yapılması
ne anlama
gelmiyor
happens before
garantisi
vermiyor
happens before
garantisinin
olması için
işte bu
az önce
söylediğim
senkronizasyon
noktalarından
birinin
söz konusu
olması
gerekiyor
şimdi o zaman
bu açıklamalardan sonra
biz nereye
dönebiliriz
atomik
değişkenlere
geri dönelim
yani atomik
değişken derken
kastetilen ne
C++'ın
standart
kütüphanesi
atomik değişkenlerle
ilgili
hangi
özelliklere
sahip
neler veriyor
neler vermiyor
bunları göreceğiz
arkadaşlar
öncelikle
şuradan
başlayalım
atomik
bir başlık
dosyası
aynı zamanda
yani
atomik işlemler
yapacaksanız
atomik
başlık
dosyasını
dahil
edeceksiniz
evet
arkadaşlar
bu
başlık
dosyası
içinde
işte
buraya da
getireyim
atomik
türler var
şimdi
yavaş yavaş
gidelim
atomik
sınıfı
aslında bir
sınıf
işte
görüyorsunuz
straktanatlar
sözcüğüyle
bildirilmiş
bir sınıf
fakat standart
kütüphane
bu jenerik
sınıf için
yani bu sınıf
şablonu için
belirli türlerine
İngilizcesiyle
hatırlayın o terimi
explicit
specialization
ya da
full specialization
aynı terim
değil mi
sağlıyor
takip edebiliyor muyuz
şurada
evet
yani
örneğin
atomik
açısal parantez
içinde
int
atomik
specialization
ayrı bir sınıf
atomik
double
specialization
ayrı bir sınıf
atomik
arkadaşlar
efendim
t yıldız
açılımı
yani
pointer
açılımı
ayrı yine
bir
partial
specialization
dolayısıyla
siz örneğin
şöyle bir
değişken
tanımladığınızda
arkadaşlar
stut
atomik
int
diyelim ki
x
böyle bir değişken
tanımladığınızda
aslında
atomik sınıf
şablonunun
int türü için
specialization'ı
full specialization'ı
kullanmış
oluyorsunuz
arkadaşlar
işte standart kütüphane
atomik
template'inin
tam sayı
gerçek sayı
açılımları için
birer specialization
veriyor size
pointer
türü
açılımları için de
yine bir
specialization
veriyor
buraya kadar
takip edebildik mi
evet
bunun dışında
buraya dikkat
size
atomik flag
isimli de
bir tür
veriyor
çoğunlukla
bakın şu ikisi
karıştırılıyor
atomik flag
bir tür
yani atomik
flag'in
kendisi
bir tür
arkadaşlar
bir de
bunda
sıklıkla
karıştırılan
stut
atomik'in
boğul
açılımı
ayrı bir tür
anlaşıldı mı
bunların
hepsini
teker teker
göreceğiz
işte bu
atomik türlerin
a
birer
interfejsi
var
o interfejisinin
olması
demek o
interfejsteki
fonksiyonları
çağırabilirsiniz
arkadaşlar
ya da
aynı zamanda
çağırabileceğiniz
bazı global
fonksiyonlar
var
ve
bu
atomik türler
üstünde
çağırdığınız
fonksiyonlar
belirli fonksiyonlar
atomik işlem
atomik
operation
garantisi
veriyor
yani örneğin
ben
yukarıdaki
gibi
hepsini
göreceğiz
yukarıdaki
gibi bir
değişken
tanımladığımda
bir threadte
artı artı
x işlemini
yaptığımda
artık
burada
başka bir
senkronizasyon
mekanizması
bir kilit
sistemi
olmadan
arkadaşlar
data race
olma
ihtimali
ortadan
kalkıyor
yani
atomik
değişken
üstünde
yapılan
atomik
işlemler
doğrudan
data race
engelliyor
bakın
bunun en tipik
örneğini
görelim
şimdi izleyin
daha önce
aradaki farkı
şimdi çok net
göreceksiniz
arkadaşlar
daha önce şöyle bir
kodda yazmıştık
özellikle
divan modunu
alayım
enter'den
x değişkeni
bakın
değeri
sıfır
void
bu
burada bir
döngü var
efendim
döngü
diyelim ki
100 bin
kere dönüyor
döngünün
her durumda
x
değişkenini
arttırıyorum
arkadaşlar
ve
bir
thread
vektörü
oluşturuyorum
stut
hatta
c
thread
olsun
bir
nesli
scope
oluşturayım
stut
vektörün
c
thread
açılımı
işte
tevek
efendim
10 kez
dönen
döngü içinde
tevek
and place
back
efendim
c
thread
nested
scope'u
kapatıyorum
nested
scope'u
kapattım
ve şimdi
oilstream
başlık dosyasını
ekledim
ve burada
x değişkeninin
değerini
yazdırdım
arkadaşlar
tabi ki
burada
herhangi bir
ne yok
arkadaşlar
koruma yok
date arayısı
olacak
dolayısıyla
normalde
işte
100.000
çarpı
arkadaşlar
1 milyon
olma garantisi
yok
daha doğrusu
bu program
zaten
tanımsız
davranışlı
işte
bakın
eğer ben
burada
örneğin
aynı
mutex'i
tek tek
gösterelim
şimdi
senkronizasyon
stut
mutex
mtx
başlık dosyasında
dahil edelim
evet
stut
mutex
mtx
arkadaşlar
hatta burada
bakın
mtx
lock
unlock
şimdi
artık
1 milyon
olma
garantisi
var
çünkü
bir senkronizasyon
sağladım
işte bakın
unlock'un
çağrılmasıyla
bir başka
thread
aynı
mutex'i
kilitlediğinde
sonucu
oluşmuş
olarak
görme
garantisinde
evet
o bir
ama
bu garantiyi
sağlamanın
tek yolu
bu değil
şimdi
değişkenime
atomik
yapıyorum
yani
intx
değil
stut
atomic
int
türünden
x
mutex'i
kapattım
sildim
lock ve unlock
fonksiyonlarını
tabi
sildim
ama
artı artı
x işlemi
aslında
burada
atomik
değişkenin
bir
üye fonksiyonunun
çağrılması
demek
bu
üye fonksiyonlarının
birazdan isimlerini
vesaire
göreceğiz
ve burada
artık
bir
thread'in
diğer thread'in
oluşturduğu
işlemin
sonucunu
görme garantisi
var
ama tabi
hangi thread
hangi noktada
görecek
onu bilmiyorum
ama
arkadaşlar
bir data race
yok
özetleyin kısa
tanımı
bir data race
yok
işte
atomik değişkenin
arkadaşlar
üstünde yapılan
bazı işlemlerin
uninterruptible
olması
kesintiye
uğramama
garantisi
a
önemli
ve
bunun dışında
sadece
kesintiye
uğramama
garantisi
yok
aynı
zamanda
ne garantisi
de var
işte
birazdan
oralara
geçeceğiz
bu derste
değil de
bundan sonraki
derste
arkadaşlar
aynı
zamanda
ne garantisi
var
bir
senkronizasyon
garantisi
var
yani
store işlemiyle
load işlemi
arasında
storedan
önceki
bellek işleminin
loaddan
sonra
görünme
garantisi
var
arkadaşlar
burada
en tipik
hatalardan
biri
burada
en tipik
hatalardan
biri
volatile
değişkenlerin
multi
thread
programlamada
C'de ya da
C++'da
senkronizasyon
garantisi
verdiğini
düşünmek
bunun da
nedenini
biliyor musunuz
java gibi
bazı
programlama
dillerinde
onlarda da
volatile
keyword'ü
var
ama
onlardaki
volatile
keyword'ü
adeta
bizim
atomik
değişkenimizin
karşılığı
ama
C++'daki
volatile'la
arkadaşlar
o java'daki
ya da
falanca dildeki
volatile
aynı şey
değil
yani
soru şöyle
olsaydı
bu değişkeni
volatile
yapsaydım
böyle bir
garanti
olacak mıydı
cevap
hayır
kesinlikle
yani
asla
volatile
ya da
nasıl
telaffuz ediyorsanız
arkadaşlar
bakın
zaten
görüyorsunuz
167.350
çıktı
1 milyon
nerede
167.350
volatile
başka
volatile'i
ben
C'de
anlatıyorum
o yüzden
C++'da
hiç
anlatmadım
bu kursa
hiç
anlatmadım
ama
bir değişkenin
volatile olması
ne demek
Mehmet Ali
C'de
ya da
C++'da
program dışı
kaynaklar
tarafından
değiştirilebilir
demek
yani
derleyiciye
diyorsunuz ki
aman
derleyici
kod üretirken
dikkat et
sen sadece
benim kodumu
görüp
ona yönelik
olarak
optimizasyon
yapıyorsun
mesela
benim kodumun
o değişkenin
değerini
değiştirmediğini
gördüğün için
nasıl olsa
değeri
değişmiyor
diye
optimizasyon
yapıyorsun
ama o değişkeni
volatile yaptığımda
sen görmüyorsun
ama program dışı
kaynaklar
bunu
değiştirebilir
her an
dolayısıyla
diyorsunuz ki
derleyiciye
programın
lojik yapısının
değişmemesi için
o değişkenin
kullanıldığı
her yerde
sen
yeniden
o değişkenin
değerini
benlikten
okuyacaksın
fetch edeceksin
yani bir yerde
register'da sakladım
nasıl değişmedi
tekrar get etmeyeyim
daha hızlı çalışsın
biçimindeki
optimizasyonların
yapılmasına
izin vermiyor
arkadaşlar
şimdi
izleyin
standart kütüphane
diyor ki
deminki
atomik
templateine
geri dönelim
sadece ve
sadece
aslında
bu
birazdan göreceğimiz
atomik
flag
türünün
lock free
olma garantisi
var
ki bizde
onunla
başlayacağız
atomik flag
ile başlayacağız
sadece
atomik flag
için
lock free
olma
garantisi
var
necati anlamadım
lock free
garantisi
ne demek
yani
buradaki
atomisite
hani
uninterruptible
olması
derleyicinin
ürettiği
kodda
derleyici
tarafında
gerçekten
bir
mutex sistemi
kullanılıyor
olabilir
yani
derleyici
size
atomik
operasyonları
aslında
arka planda
kendi
implementasyonunda
bir
kilit sistemi
kullanarak
örneğin bir
mutex
kullanarak
size bu
olanağı
sağlayabilir
standart
bunu
derleyiciye
bırakmış
ya da
hayır
söz konusu
işlemci de
bunu
sağlayan
yani
işlemin
doğrudan
işlemcinin
komutuyla
atomik olarak
yapılmasını
sağlaması
söz konusu
olabilir ki
bunu da
compile time'da
ya da
run time'da
test edebiliyorsunuz
ama şimdi
bu
atomik flag
türü
lock free
olmak zorunda
o garantiyi
veriyor
bakın bu
ayrı bir tür
ismi
stud
atomic
flag
arkadaşlar
aslında
en temel
operasyonlarda
kullandığımız
tür
bu
atomik flag
türü
atomik
flag
türü
bir
değişken
örneğin
x
biz sadece
belirli fonksiyonları
çağırabiliyoruz
arkadaşlar
zaten bu fonksiyonların
bir kısmı da
şeyi
tamamen
c++
20 ile
eklendi
yani şimdi ben
notify all
ve notify one'ı
hiç konuşmayacağım
ama c++
20'den
ya da
wait
notify all
notify one
bunlar yeni
aslında bunun
clear
değil
de c++
20 ile
geldi
arkadaşlar
sadece ve sadece
iki tane
fonksiyonu var
arkadaşlar
test and set
izleyin
test hadi bir de
clear'i de
alalım
arkadaşlar
son derece basit
buraya dikkat
artık burada
çok fazla kod olduğu için
bütün örneklerde
kod yazmadan
örnekler üstüne
gideceğim
şöyle önce
atomic flag
türünün
temel özelliklerini
görelim
ondan sonra da
mesela bu
hangi senaryolarda
işe yarar
ona bir bakalım
arkadaşlar
izleyin
atomic flag
türünden
bir değişkeni
böyle doğrudan
boolean değerle
ne yapamıyoruz
initialize
edemiyoruz
yani örneğin
buradaki
tanımda
doğrudan
atomic flag'i
false
yani boolean bir değerine
başlatmak
sentaks hatası
ister false
olsun
ister true
devam ediyoruz
arkadaşlar
default
construct
ettiğinizde
burada da
enteresan bir
gelişme
oldu
c++
17'de
bu değişkenin
değeri
indetermined
value
yani
değişkenin
değerini
kullanamıyordunuz
yani
aslında
c++
20'den
önce
arkadaşlar
sizin
atomik bir
değişkeni
kullanabilmeniz
için
yani onu
indetermined
value'dan
çıkartmanız
için
yine
atomik
başlık
dosyasına
verilen
bir makroyla
initialize
etmeniz
gerekiyordu
yani ancak
şu şekilde
tanımladığınızda
arkadaşlar
geçerli
oluyordu
ve
değişkenin
değeri
efendim
false
oluyordu
ama
şimdi
c++
20 ile
birlikte
default
construct
ettiğinizde
yine
artık
ne olma
garantisi
var
indetermined
value
olmama
garantisi
var
hatta ben
tek tek
göstermek
istiyorum
c++
ise
kullanmayın
bu kodu
ama
c++
20'de
arkadaşlar
görüyorsunuz
flag underscore
z değişkenin
değeri
false
şimdi
bunu
sildim
atomic flag
init
makrosunu
kullandım
bu arada
test fonksiyonu
da az önce
söylediğim gibi
c++
20 ile
geldi
yani
atomic
değişkenin
değerini
get ediyor
booleum
döndürüyor
flag'in
yine
false
olduğunu
görüyorsunuz
arkadaşlar
burada
doğrusu
isterseniz
eskiden
zaten
tek fonksiyon
buydu
en önemli
fonksiyon
test and set
fonksiyonu
atomic flag'in
test and set
fonksiyonu
atomic flag'i
set ediyor
yani
booleum
true'ya
çekiyor
ve eski
değerini
get ediyor
e şimdi
bakın
şuraya kadar
yazalım
b'nin
değeri
yani
test and set'in
geri dönüş
değerini
değeriyle
b
değişkenini
hayata
getirdim
b'nin
booleum
olduğunu
görüyorsunuz
çünkü
test and set'in
geri dönüş
değeri
türü
booleum
ve bu
değeri
yazdırıyorum
aslında
şunları da
silelim
evet
bakın
şu anda
hayata
başladığında
false
değeri oldu
değerinin
false
olduğunu
standart
altlıkta
yazdırdım
test and set'in
geri dönüş
değerini
booleum
bir değişkende
sakladım
test and set
eski değeri
get ediyor
yeni değeri
set ediyor
dolayısıyla
bakınız
set edilmesi
demek
onun
arkadaşlar
görüyorsunuz
bakın
b'nin değeri
ve
sonra
flag'in
tekrar
test fonksiyonunu
çağırıyor
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
geri dönüş
değeri
false
ama yeni
değeri
true
bu basit
fonksiyonla
çok temel
kilit sistemini
İngilizce'de
spinlock
denilen
kilit sistemini
oluşturabiliyorsunuz
birazdan bir
spinlock
örneği vereceğim
arkadaşlar
bu arada
C++
mülakatlarında
yine en sık
sorulan
sorulardan biri
spinlock
nedir
basit bir
spinlock
sınıfını
implemente
ediniz
gibi
evet
sadece
atomic flag
türünü
kullanarak
bir spinlock
oluşturabilir miyim
cevap
evet
yine
şu anda
true olmuştu
clear fonksiyonunu
çağırıyorum
clear fonksiyonunda
değeri
arkadaşlar
false'a çekiyor
o zaman
test and set
true'ya çekiyor
clear
false'a çekiyor
C++
20 standardıyla
gelen
testte
o andaki
değerini
veriyor
evet
arkadaşlar
yine bakın
16.
satıra geldiğimizde
ondan önce
clear çağırısı
yaptığımız için
flag'in değeri
tekrar
false oldu
şimdi yine
test and set'i
çağırdım
ama en son
true'ydu
arkadaşlar
pardon
en son
false'du
şimdi false
döndürecek
ama değeri de
tekrar
true'ya
çekecek
böylece
aslında tek bir
basit örnekte
atomic flag'in
clear
test
test and set
fonksiyonlarını
görmüş olduk
arkadaşlar
bakın şimdi
bir
spin lock
oluşturacağız
şimdi
lock'ın ne olduğunu
biliyorsunuz
kilitin ne olduğunu
mutex'in ne olduğunu
biliyorsunuz
mutex'in bir
lock ve unlock
fonksiyonu var ya
pek şimdiye kadar
şunu hiç
sorgulamadık
mutex
sınıfı nasıl
oluşturuluyor
nasıl oluyor da
mesela mutex
kilitleme sağlıyor
kritik bölgeye
diğer kodların
girmesini
engelliyor
işte
aslında
mutex de
mutex
implementasyonlarda
test and set
farklı duruyor
set edemediği
bir durum
var mı
hayır
buradaki set
herhangi bir
değerle set etmek
anlamında değil
Mehmet Ali Bey
buradaki set
yani
true yapmak
demek
siz test and set
fonksiyonunu
çağırdığınızda
atomic flag'i
true değerine
çekiyorsunuz
ama
eski değerini
yet ediyorsunuz
yani örneğin
değeri zaten
true iken
tekrar test and set'i
çağırırsanız
geri dönüş
değeri
true olacak
ama
false iken
test and set'i
çağırırsanız
geri dönüş
değeri
false olacak
ama
atomic
flag değişkenimizin
kendi değeri
true olacak
anlaşıldı mı
evet
şimdi gelin
bu kilit sistemine
nasıl oluyor da
mesela ben
lag fonksiyonunu
çağırdığımda
işte kilidi
kilitlemiş oluyorum
kritik bölgeye
diğer tracklerin
gelmesi
engelleniyor
onlar
blok oluyor
arkadaşlar
bunu en basit
şekilde
tabi normal
mütex böyle
oluşturulmuyor
ama
spin lag derken
aslında kastetilen
şu
hiç bloke etmeden
bloke olmadan
sürekli
sorgulama yapacak
yani
çok kısa
beklemeler için
yani
eğer o bekleme
süresi
işlemin yapılması
hani kilit
yani kilit
kritik bölgeye
girdik
o kritik bölgede
çok çok kısa
sürede kalıyorsa
bu sefer
spin lag
türü bir
kilit
bir mütex
çok daha
verimli
olabiliyor
peki
spin lag
örneğin
kendimiz böyle
bir sınıfı
oluşturursak
nasıl
oluşturacağız
bu
az önce
söylediğim
atomic flag'i
kullanarak
arkadaşlar
bakın
son derece
basit
şu benim
sınıfım olsun
class
spin lag
mütex
public
normal
mütex gibi
gerçekten
kullanacağım
bunun bir
lag
fonksiyonu olacak
arkadaşlar
bir de
an lag
fonksiyonu olacak
minimal
yani
bu ne demek
az önceki örnekte
şöyle yapalım
şunu
grip
orta atalım
şimdi geri dönelim
demin
şu 1 milyon
örneği vardı ya
tamam
bakın
buradaki
mütex'i
birazdan
değiştireceğim
arkadaşlar
spin lag
mütex yapacağım
open
çizmesine
bakmayın
ve
yine
senkronizasyon
sağlanmış
olacak
şimdi işte o
spin lag
mütex
sınıfını
yazıyoruz
bir iki bir lag
bir unlag
fonksiyonu var
ama
bakın
lag ve unlag
nasıl
implement ettiğime
bakın
arkadaşlar
aslında
sınıfa
bir
non-static
data member
koyuyorum
stud
autonomic flag'in
yani şu anda
üstünde konuştuğumuz
türden
bir veri elemanı
diyelim ki
m
lag
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
arkadaşlar
default
construct
edildiğinde
artık
ne olma garantisi
var
false olma garantisi
onu da söyleyeyim
şimdi
bir tane
constructor
ama yine de
ben o garantiye
güvenmeyeceğim
açık açık
göstereceğim
neydi ismi
spin lag
mütex
constructor
aslında
veri elemanı
olan
atomic flag'in
clear fonksiyonunu
çağıracak
m
flag
clear
çok basit bir
kod
ama yavaş yavaş
gidiyorum ki
birazdan karmaşık
hale geleceksen
şimdi
o zaman
ben bir
spin lag
mütex
nesnesini
construct
ettiğimde
onun veri elemanı
olan
atomic flag'in
false değerde
olduğunu
garanti etmiş
oluyorum
arkadaşlar
şimdi lag
fonksiyonuna
bakın
buraya bir döngü
koysam
bu döngü
bu
kadar basit bir döngü ki
bakın
m flag'in
testen set fonksiyonunu
çağıracak
ve testen set fonksiyonu
arkadaşlar
true değer döndüğü sürece
bu döngü dönecek
takip edebiliyor muyuz
buraya kadar
anladık mı
arkadaşlar
döngünün gövdesinde
özellikle null statement
olduğuna
dikkat edin
bu ne demek
e bu döngüden
çıkması için
bu ifadenin
arkadaşlar
ne olması gerekir
false olması gerekir
dolayısıyla bu true olduğu sürece
dönecek
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
arkadaşlar
ne zaman
m flag testen set
false değer dönecek
o zaman
bu döngüden
çıkacak
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
dolayısıyla
bunun false dönmesi demek
eski değerin
false olması
ama yeni değerin
true olması demek
buraya anladık mı
bu da aslında
mutex'i
kilitlemek demek
anlak fonksiyonu
yapacağı hiçbir şey yok
anlak fonksiyonu da
tekrar
mutex'i
mutex'i diyorum
atomic flag'i
m flag'i
clear edecek
yani
false değeri çekecek
arkadaşlar
kod biraz karmaşık gibi geliyor ama
aslında son derece basit
şimdi anlak demek
biz
bu atomic flag'i
false durumuna getirdik demek
yani herhangi bir thread
bizim spin lock'ımızı
anlak ettiğinde
zaten
bu atomic flag
veri elemanımız
false hale gelecek
bu durumda
arkadaşlar
aynı nesnenin
lock fonksiyonunu
çağıran
bir thread
eğer bunu
ne durumda
yakalarsa
false durumda
ve onu
true'ya çekerse
bu döngüden çıkacak
necati olur mu
gerçekten
eğer
evet bakın
herhangi bir hata
yapmadıysak
başka bir hata
var mı
bakın
derledim
kızarken bir hata
yapmadığımı
umuyorum
evet ve
görüyorsunuz
gerçekten
1 milyon
işte
olabilecek
en basit
spin lock
sınıfı
bu şekilde
ne yapılabilir
arkadaşlar
implement edilebilir
ama burada bir şey görüyorsunuz
değil mi
burada bloke falan yok
burada
herhangi bir şekilde
bir bloke yok
yani
kilitlemeye çalışırken
biz aslında
sürekli testten seti çağırıyoruz
herhangi bir şekilde
kilit başkasındayken
thread bloke oluyor mu
hayır
o yüzden
bu ancak
ne zaman
tercih edilebilir
işte çok kısa
beklemelerde
arkadaşlar
çok kısa
beklemelerde
anlaşıldı mı
evet
gerçekten de
bakın
bizim
otomik değişkenimizin
değeri
diyorum
paylaşılmış değişkenimizin
intürden x değişkenimizin
değeri
arkadaşlar
1 milyon oldu
aliham bozkır
gerekli
interfej hazırlarsak
lock ray
sınıflarıyla da
sarmalayarak
kullanabiliriz
değil mi
bunu
evet
arkadaşlar zaten
ne diyor
mesela
bizim
lock card sınıfı
da bir template
değil mi
zaten lock card sınıfı
ne diyor
benim diyor
template argümanımın
lockable olması
gerekiyor
şu demek
öyle bir tür olacak ki
o türün
arkadaşlar
lock ve unlock
fonksiyonları
olacak
arkadaşıma sorusu
son derece önemli
şunu demek istiyor
aliham
ki haklı
mesela diyor
necati
şöyle yapsam
izleyin
burada
lock ve unlock
fonksiyonlarını
çağırmasam
mutex
dahil edilmiş olsun
burada
lock ve unlock
fonksiyonlarını
çağırmasam
ama
stud
lock card'ın
lock card
lock
ve
mtx
takip edebiliyor muyuz
yine şu anda
ray ile
sarmalamış oldum
mu
tabi ki
kesinlikle
hatta hatta
aliham bir şeyi
daha fark ettiniz mi
neden de
faydalanmış oldum
burada
sitattan da
faydalanmış oldum
normalde
şöyle yazmam
gerekirdi
değil mi
spin
lock
mutex
açılımı
ama
mtx'in
türü
zaten bu
olduğundan
arkadaşlar
efendim
herhangi bir şekilde
gerek kalmadı
ama şimdi
diğer
atomik türlere
geçelim
bu arada
tekrar söylüyorum
atomik flag'in
yani şu anda
konuştuğumuz
hani
sadece
clear
test and set
c++20 ile
test
fonksiyonu
geldi dedim
bu fonksiyonları
olan bu sınıfın
lock free
olma garantisi var
yani hiçbir
implementasyonda
bunun bir
örneğin
arka planda
mutex ile
implemente edilmiş
olma ihtimali
yok
arkadaşlar
şimdi
şu
atomik
sınıfının
üye fonksiyonlarına
bakalım
şimdi nereye
geldik aslında
atomik flag'i
geçtik
hani
stut
atomik bir
templetti ya
atomik'in
int açılımı
efendim
double açılımı
Mermet Aleyhgeci
hocam bu flag'i
bir thread set edince
başka bir thread
set edemiyor mu
ya da
bloke mi oluyor
az önceki örnekten
bahsediyorsunuz
orayı kaçırmış
olmalısınız
işte oranın cevabı
şu
şimdi
bir daha bakalım
dedim ya
biraz karmaşık gibi
görünüyor
aslında son derece
basit
şimdi bakın
birden fazla
thread'in
aynı mutex'i
kullandığını
düşünelim
sadece takip edin
ve
aynı spinlock mutex'i
kullandığını
düşünelim
ve spinlock mutex'in
m flag elemanının
false olduğunu
düşünelim
o zaman
thread'lerden
birinde
lock fonksiyonu
çağrıldığında
buraya dikkat
thread'lerden
birinde
lock fonksiyonu
çağrıldığında
değerli arkadaşlar
aslında
şu fonksiyon
çağrılacak
bir döngüsler
yapı içinde
değil mi
tamam
kaç tane
thread olursa
olsun
o atomik
flag değişkenimizin
değeri
false değil mi
onlardan
bir tanesi
false'u
true'ya
çekecek
ve geri dönüş
değeri
false olacak
döngüden
çıkacak
Mehmet Ali
buraya kadar
takip edebildiniz mi
işte
onu false
yakalayıp
true haline
getiren
thread
aslında
kilidi
kilitlemiş olacak
onun bakış açısıyla
peki oraya gelen
diğer thread'ler
bizim
thread'lerden
biri kilitledi ya
o zaman
burada dönmeye
başlayacaklar
değil mi
çünkü test
and set
fonksiyonu
arkadaşlar
ne hale getirmek
istiyor
ne dönüyor
burada
sürekli
true dönüyor
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
e true dönüyor
zaten spin
hani
normal
şeyler
halk arasında da
böyle bir terim var
yarı Türkçe
yarı İngilizce
spin attı
falan diyorlar
yani burada
spin'e giriyor
ne zaman
bu spin'den
çıkacak
işte
o kilidi
lock fonksiyonunu
çağırıp
ele geçiren
kilitleyen
onun
unlock fonksiyonunu
çağırılacak
dolayısıyla
bu değişkenin
değeri
sınıfın
veri elemanı
olan değişkenin
değeri
tekrar
olsa olacak
o zaman
bir tanesi
bu sefer
yakalayacak
o alacak
yani iki
thread varsa
zaten
diğeri bırakınca
diğeri alacak
anladınız değil mi
ya işte
bakın
olabilecek
en basit
mutex sınıfı
ama tekrar söylüyorum
burada ne yok
bir bloke yok
hocam
const bir fonksiyon
için
yine
mutable
gerekecek
değil mi
tabii ki
olsa neden
e çünkü
görüyorsunuz
spin lock
mutex'in
lock ve unlock
fonksiyonları
post bir fonksiyon
değil
anlaşıldı
değil mi
bu da sınıfın
veri elemanı
olduğu için
dediğiniz gibi
mutable olması
gerekecek
şimdi şuraya
geri dönelim
ve şöyle
çok hızlı bir
şekilde
c++
haricindeki
atomic
template'inden
oluşturulmuş
specialization'larda
hangi fonksiyonları
var
ona bakalım
arkadaşlar
operatör atama
fonksiyonu
adı üstünde
atama yapıyor
yani
örneğin
atomic
int
türünden
bir değişkene
atama yapmak
için
sınıfın
atama
operatör
fonksiyonunu
çağırabilirsiniz
is lockfree
fonksiyonu
atomik
değişkenimizin
lockfree
olup olmadığını
sınıyor
yani lockfree ise
boolean
döndürüyor
aksi halde
false
döndürüyor
store fonksiyonu
işte
atomik değişkene
değer
yerleştiriyor
yani
aslında
atama
operatörüyle
stores
aynı işi
yapıyor
anlaşıldı
değil mi
evet
devam ediyoruz
lock
fonksiyonu
atomik değişkenin
değerini
döndürüyor
bu arada
bakınız
operatör
atama da
store da
lockta
bunların
hepsi
sonuçta ne
atomik
operasyonlar
tür dönüştürme
operatör
fonksiyonu
t
arkadaşlar
aslında
lock
fonksiyonunu
çağırıyor
yani
atomik
nesnenin
değerini
elde ediyor
bu da ne
demek
siz örneğin
atomik
intin
sınıfının
int açılımı
türünden
bir nesnenin
taşıdığı
o int
değeri elde
etmek
isterseniz
ya
load
fonksiyonunu
çağıracaksınız
ya da
tür dönüştürme
operatör
fonksiyonunu
çağıracaksınız
exchange
fonksiyonu
atomik
nesnenin
değerini
değiştiriyor
yani eski değeri
get ediyor
yeni değeri
set ediyor
ama işte
burada bizim
en fazla
zamanımızı
alacak
başlangıçta
biraz anlaması
zor olan
compare
exchange
strong
fonksiyonu
ya da
compare
exchange
weak
fonksiyonu
arkadaşlar
genel olarak
programlamada
bu
bizim
standart
kütüphanemizdeki
atomik
sınıfının
compare
exchange
strong
fonksiyonu
ya da
compare
exchange
weak
fonksiyonunun
yaptığı işi
İngilizce'de
kısaltmayla
arkadaşlar
ne deniyor
KAS deniyor
aslında tahmin edin
KAS neyin kısaltması
artık İngilizce'yi
nasıl okursanız
çünkü bu bir akronim
compare
and
swap
arkadaşlar
gerçekten
atomik değişkenlerle
ilgili
ben de
zamanda
ne zaman
bilmiyorum
işte
bunlarla
ilk tanıştığımda
beni en çok
yoran
herkes için de
aynı şey
şu KAS işleminin
C++'dan
bahsetmiyorum
yani genel olarak
programlamadan
multi-truck
bahsediyorum
ilk kez
herkes bu
compare
and swap
işlemiyle
karşılaştığında
bir tökez diyor
ne olduğunu
anlamakta
ya da neden
böyle bir işlemin
böyle bir atomik işlemin
olduğunu anlamakta
ciddi bir zorluk çekiyor
ama öğrendiğiniz zaman
bir sorun yok
arkadaşlar
şurada
hemen göstermek istiyorum
şimdi bakın
aslında bunların
her biri son derece basit
mesela
operatör atamayı
açalım
bunların hepsini
kodla göstereceğim
arkadaşlar
dikkat ederseniz
operatör atama
atomik
int açılımı
atomik değişkene
ne değer
yerleştirecekseniz
onu istiyor
ve geri dönüşleri
burada bir şeye
daha dikkat edelim
arkadaşlar
normalde
atama operatörleri
L-value expression
oluşturur
ama atomik
bir istisna
atomik
bu operatör atama
fonksiyonu
L-value expression
oluşturmuyor
yani geri dönüş
değeri referans
türü değil
ona dikkat
bu arada
bu atomik
konularını
falan anlatırken
şu
desire
ne demek
istemek
arzu etmek
demek
desire
arzu edilen
istenilen
demek
işte bakın
atomik değişkene
vermek istediğimiz
değerden
bahsederken
biraz konuşma
kolaylığı
olsun
diye
arkadaşlar
desire
ne diyelim
kullanılıyor
yani
atomik
operatör fonksiyonunun
parametresi
yüklemek
istediğiniz
değer
yani bu da
ne demek
örneğin
x atomik
bir değişkense
şuraya yazalım
x eşittir
5 dediğinizde
bu işlem
atomik olarak
yapılıyor
bu bir
atomik operasyon
işte burada
çağırılan
yani böyle
yazmakla
x'in
operatör
atama fonksiyonunu
çağırayım
ve ona
işte
bunu argüman
olarak göndereyim
aynı şey
anlaşıldı mı
arkadaşlar
atomikleri
biraz yavaş
geçmek
gerekiyor
aslında
yani bizim
de zaman
sıkıntımız
olduğu için
belki konu
yarım kalacak
ben ilave
belki video
koyabilirim
anlaşıldı
değil mi
atomik operatör
fonksiyonu
sınıf
kopyalamaya
ve taşımaya
karşı kapatılmış
yani atomik
değişkenleri
ne kopyalayabilirsiniz
ne
taşıyabilirsiniz
dolayısıyla
special member
fonksiyonu
olan
atomik operatör
fonksiyonunun
ne yapıldığını
görüyorsunuz
arkadaşlar
delete edildiğini
görüyorsunuz
devam
ee
şimdi gelelim
store'a
arkadaşlar
store'un
diğerinden
tek farkı
buraya dikkat
aslında
bir
memory order
parametresi
alması ki
onu en son
konuşacağız
bir de
geri dönüş
değerinin
arkadaşlar
void olması
volatile
overloadları
neye yarıyor
bunu ayrı
konuşalım
şimdi oraya
girmek
istemiyorum
yani orası
aslında
hem çok önemli
değil
hem de
gereğinden
fazla formal
o yüzden
asıl kritik
yere gelelim
bakın şimdi
ikinci default
parametre
default argümanı
saymazsak
store'u
çağırdığınızda
ona da
yüklenmesi
istenen
değeri geçiyorsunuz
yani yine
x bir
atomik değişkense
x'in
store'u
örneğin
12 dersem
atomik değişkenimin
değerini
12'ye
çekiyorum
yani aslında
yukarıdaki
fonksiyonda
aşağıdaki
sonuç olarak
aynı işi yapıyor
birinin
geri dönüş
değeri var
birinin
geri dönüş
değeri yok
ve bir şeye
dikkat edin
atom operatör
fonksiyonuyla
bir farkı daha var
store fonksiyonunun
memory order
dediğimiz
ikinci bir
parametresi var
biz şimdi
ondan hiç
bahsetmedik
şimdi hep
default argüman
kullanacağız
ama
atom operatör
fonksiyonunun
nesi yok
arkadaşlar
böyle bir
ikinci parametresi
yok
devam ediyorum
load fonksiyonu
izleyin
yine aynı şekilde
parametre değişkeni
default argüman
oluyor
o memory order'a
bundan sonraki
derste gireceğim
memory order
değerini
default argüman
olarak alıyor
ve geri dönüş
değeri de
atomik değişkenin
değeri
ama bunlar
hepsi şimdiye kadar
bahsettiğimiz
atomik işler
yani örneğin
böyle bir
fonksiyon çağrısıyla
atomik değişkenimin
değerini
12 yaptım
böyle bir
fonksiyon çağrısıyla
atomik değişkenin
değerini
kullanıyor
durumdayım
load'un geri dönüş
değeri
arkadaşlar
atomik değişkenin
değeri
yani atomik değişkeni
değer yükleyen
store fonksiyonunu
çağıracak
burada
store ile load
başlangıçta
ilk defa
bu sözlüklerle
tanışanlara
sanki
ters olması
gerekiyormuş gibi
gelebilir
ama store
işte saklamak
demek değil mi
set etmek
load'da
hani bir şeyi
load ettiğinizde
onu
onun değerini
almış oluyorsunuz
oradan
değer çekmiş oluyorsunuz
yani
adeta şöyle
düşünmelisiniz
bu sanki
set
bu da
sanki
yetmiş
gibi
store değer
yüklüyor
load
yüklenmiş
değeri
çekiyor
yine
tıklı
store'da
olduğu gibi
load'da da
parametre
değişkenini
default
argüman
aldığını
görüyorsunuz
1-2 dakikada
tutacağım
size
operatör
tür dönüştürme
fonksiyonu
arkadaşlar
son derece
basit
t türüne
dönüşüm
sağlıyor
yani
memory
order
parametresi
yok
ama
çağırdığınız zaman
arkadaşlar
load fonksiyonunu
çağırıyor
yani load fonksiyonunu
default
memory
order'la
çağırmaya
eş değer
devam edelim
exchange
şimdi
fonksiyonu
görüyorsunuz
arkadaşlar
birinci
parametresine
yüklenmek
yükleyeceğiniz
değeri
alıyor
fakat
geri dönüş
değeri de
eski
yani
bu şu
demek
normalde
siz
store'la
atomik olarak
değer yüklüyorsunuz
load'la
atomik olarak
değeri çekiyorsunuz
ama
exchange'in
kendisi de
atomik bir işlem
ama
ikisini
birlikte yapıyor
yani
yine
x
bir
atomik
değişken
olmak üzere
x'in
exchange'i
örneğin
dediğinizde
atomik
int olsun
arkadaşlar
atomik değişkenimizin
değeri
oldu
ve bu
ifadenin
değeri de
diyelim ki
daha önceki
değer
12 ise
o yüzden
exchange
önemli
ama bakın
bu fonksiyonların
hepsinin
istisnasız
bir
memory
order
parametresi
var
ve o
bütün fonksiyonlarda
memory
order
parametresi
default
argüman
olarak
şu değeri
oluyor
ki
bu da
aslında
belki bu
terimle
diğer programlama
dillerinde
konuşmuş
olabilirsiniz
concurrency
konusunda
bu da
sequential
consistency
dediğimiz
bellek
üstünde
sequential
consistency
dediğimiz
garantiye
elde etmeye
yönelik
evet
devam
arkadaşlar
şimdi
wait
notify
one
all
bunlardan
hiç bahsetmeyeceğim
c++20
burada en önemli
fonksiyon
yani uzaklara
anlamamız gereken
en önemli
fonksiyon
arkadaşlar
compare
exchange
strong
bakınız
şimdi
memory
order
parametrelerini
yazmazsam
yani onlar
şimdilik konumuz
değil
compare
exchange
strong
ilk defa
tanışanlar
için
adeta
komik bir
fonksiyon
ne yapıyor
bakınız
şimdi
fonksiyonun
birinci
parametresi
dikkat ediyor
musunuz
l value
referans
yani
atomic
intin
compare
exchange
strong
fonksiyonunun
birinci
parametresi
intref
compare
exchange
strong
arkadaşlar
atomik
intin
compare
exchange
strong
fonksiyonunun
birinci
parametresi
intref
ikinci
parametresi
int
siz bu
fonksiyonu
çağırmakla
aslında
atomik
değişkene
bu değeri
yüklemek
istiyorsunuz
ama bir
koşulla
eğer
atomik
değişkeninizin
değeri
burada
birinci
parametreye
geçtiğiniz
değersi
yani örneğin
expected
değeri
5se
desired
değeri
10sa
ve bu
noktada
gerçekten
bu fonksiyon
çağrıldığında
atomik
değişkenimizin
değeri
5se
yani
expected
eşitse
atomik
değişkenimizin
değerini
yapıyor
ve
true
dönüyor
bu
anlaması
biraz
zor
tekrar edeyim mi
eğer
değer
yani
değer derken
atomik
değişkenin
değerinden
bahsediyorum
expected
ise
yani
expect
bu fonksiyona
geçtiğiniz
değeri
neyse
ona eşitse
o zaman
değer
değişecek
yani
atomik
değerin
değeri
atomik
değişkenimizin
değeri
değişecek
ve
değeri
ne olacak
bizarre
de olacak
peki
bu durumda
fonksiyonun
kullanım
amacı
zaten
bütün
hikaye
o
kullanım
amacı
en zor
anlaşılması
gereken
yer
orası
ama
bir dahaki
derste
kaldı
aya
desired
olacak
ve fonksiyonumuz
ne değer
döndürecek
bu
türden
true
değer
döndürecek
anlaşıldı mı
ama
şimdi ilginç
noktaya
bakın
peki
ya
atomik
değişkenimizin
değeri
birinci
parametresine
geçtiğimiz
expected
değeri
değilse
eğer
değer
expected
değil
ise
buraya
dikkat
bu durumda
arkadaşlar
referans
semanti ile
alıyor ya
expected
değerini
değişkeninin
atomik
değişkenimizin
değeri
yapacak
arkadaşlar
ve
buraya
dikkat
atomik
değişkenimizin
değeri
desired
olmayacak
takip
edebiliyor
muyuz
evet
arkadaşlar
şimdi
diyeceksiniz ki
bu ne işe
yarıyor
zaten
bütün
bu
anlattığımın
örneği ne
bundan sonraki
derste
göreceğiz
ama
burada bir şeye
dikkat
bu halen
atomik bir
operasyon
bu halen
atomik bir
operasyon
arkadaşlar
ama en azından
şunu anladınız
değil mi
ne zamanki
atomik
değişkenin
değeri
değişecek
yani bu
desert
olacak
o zaman
true
dönecek
onun dışında
hep
sos
dönecek
dolayısıyla
ben bunu örneğin
döngüsel bir
yapıda
çağırırsam
ve döngüyü
compare exchange
strong
fonksiyonunun
geri dönüş
değeri
false
olduğu sürece
dönen bir
döngü
yaparsam
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
arkadaşlar
bu durumda
bu döngüden
çıkması için
atomik
değişkenimizin
değerinin
değişmesi
gerekiyor
peki
cuma günü
dersimizde
devam
edeceğiz
ve özellikle
compare exchange
strong
ne işe yarıyor
arkadaşlar
buradaki
rolü ne
onunla ilgili
örnekler
yapacağız
peki
derse katıldığınız için
teşekkür ediyorum
aynı saatte
evet
cuma günü
aynı saatte
normalde
benim
c++
kursum vardı
onu
iptal edeceğim
yani
başka bir
c++
kursum vardı
cuma günü
artık
kursu
bitireceğiz
peki
cuma günü
görüşmek üzere
herkese
iyi akşamlar
diliyorum
hoşçakalın
değerli arkadaşlar
ıhfı
ıhı
cım
Configura
ıhı